[Music]
thank you
sir
my check my check
[Music]
Sunday around
Lord God
what's going on around talk to me how my
levels are sounding make sure I'm
sounding all right out here
[Music]
oh hold on hold on shout out to the
homie hustling motivate brother it's
great to see you good talking with you
yesterday
always a pleasure always a pleasure one
of the good ones pop now what's going on
Mr ordinary not regular all right all
right all right created in time card for
the top rope yeah come from the top
that was that wrestling stream you know
what I'm saying well I've Metroid up in
there fresh and early as always talking
that Nintendo talk I like to see it
Black Lightning what's going on
wow
[Music]
oh no doubt Brothers
energy
[Music]
when you old you know you just roll out
of the bed you know I'm saying that's
that's just type attitude thing oh yeah
we have a good show we got some fun
topics
[Music]
we will see y'all
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and hell is be swearing it real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was
[Music]
get back
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original you're also Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social lower my CD
but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know about to
get started I am well it's not important
who I am uh what's important is that you
are pulling up to the iron Lords podcast
right now as we speaking uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
am look y'all messed up and turned me to
an animal and headers be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when he was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social knowing my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
um
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put on the bo dog thing very
loyal but I ain't gonna hold y'all I
ain't heard a boy and you ain't gotta
say it I'm embarrassed for you I always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Voltron with a gang of cougars in them
going places better Uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain uses the
target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got it
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to Freddy
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just for
your original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
uses the target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start with regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
and I'm going places better tell a uber
cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
[Music]
videos
I'ma just chill and watch them and he
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if I can imagine it's cool to get
you some advice and invite your girl to
your squadron cause if you don't give
her that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by King David
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental was an avatar to a knee
vendor I gotta be Neato I know it's my
destiny word to carnido who cares if he
flies you still a mosquito you swear he
ain't something but really be Stevo you
like to collect stuff and that's cool
but I got bad news even if you really
was that joke King David still be the
king of the statue since the juvenile
I've been cursed with a curse to be
Musical and if you hate it we'll meet in
The Crucible wasn't it nothing it's cool
and it's beautiful we let you know that
your dreams are pursuable whatever you
want to do then it's doable if you got
work on a Sunday it's suitable cause you
can listen to this and you're cubicle on
the Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord okay
[Music]
the hottest the hottest of bikes
like checking all that let's talk to the
people right quick oh we what's going on
let me hear you right quick man let me
hear you right quick
[Laughter]
all right all right here you hear me and
we are live and welcome to the iron
Lords podcast LLC and also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 294 234
episodes y'all that's crazy
it must be bananas
I hope it's bananas I hope so too
another glorious bananas attic pause
time we gotta put time before the intro
what's funny what's funny is if if if I
say something sus to that sus comment
he's gonna say I'm the susp one yeah
and today we've got whoa long Fallen
Dynasty Sony must reveal their
exclusivity deals
with the snitching goes wrong
yo you stupid that was good it's kind of
fun
all right I'll give you that that was
kind of funny
ABK deal
um an EU update and Destiny 2 lightfall
to discuss so we gonna get right to it
so let's introduce the Four Horsemen of
gaming those original gaming Knights of
the realm here at the round table my
co-host Nicole Mouse my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror Lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf my man Lord addict
of the attic show and the new wrestler
in WWE 2K whatever it was when we played
22 22 okay what's good
pressure for coming uh coming through uh
especially people you know had like you
know 50 60 people came through to the uh
I did like an IOP pre-show on my channel
you know I I show people that lubu is a
is annoying but if you know how to fight
them you know you can easily beat him
beat him on my first attempt may I say
something I'll tell them
Nick said glad to see King got some heat
in his house
yo is he subscribed put the band on
describe the only chat is
an issue
Silence
of him
put him in the furnace
it's a real quick drive by this like
this
keep scrolling
the heresy man good to see you look
better yeah yeah
it's like the 50 mean with 50 look at
you in Chicago
still no heat in the house bro shut up
yo they going in King paid the bill
finally wow they going in it
still freezing anyway what has a lord
lubu been up to sir
oh just
been doing stuff man but uh all right
yeah
smooth was stuck on them for like a week
like he had two live streams it was kind
of funny but you know I I had a pretty
good show with that we are going to you
know be doing a lot of stuff here in the
next couple we we started our prep work
for PAX East yes
looking through some of the games
someone needs to get part of the Trello
board well I'm Paul I'm already part of
it oh really
the news today
someone it's right there
let me click it let me see we can
discuss later
remember last year he was like yeah you
can't go to the uh to the the gearbox
event
go someplace else
it takes Sovereign
we are going to try to get some stuff
going for you guys it depends on what
actually happens uh but you know we
appreciate everyone coming through we
have a good show for you guys uh I think
people are gonna like the uh show that
we got going on yeah man I think so
what's that bar under the bottom since
she was like rolled the packs what's
that about
oh well I mean clearly it says right
there you know we we got something but
somebody new comes in and they see the
ball and they don't understand what the
bar is why are you acting like that
since you started talking about I
thought you were just like so okay so as
you guys could see because apparently
King got amnesia but it's okay
he need to explain it he didn't explain
it and it is in color it is it is yellow
so you can definitely see that yeah so
the more you talk about the more the
more the the ball so if you look down
you'll see you know you've got the
48.49 yeah what happens when we hit 50
is uh what we we do another another
event and that that is going to be the
the Retro you know
ridiculous yeah
[Laughter]
that's wild disrespectful yo you know
what why don't you super chat some more
so I can get some more heat yeah
if you look you know we got 48 we about
to hit 50. you know once we hit that 50
go we owe you guys another Community
stream yes sir and we uh owe you a retro
and pretty much what the Retro is you
can make any Lord play a retro game I.E
added you can play attic player Retro
Game I played enough make the people
that no first off let's make these old
heads play the games that they played
they good at it because people have
spoken the people have spoken and they
love Millennial places
you know what's funny they're gonna be
sitting here talking all this smack and
I bet you they don't do half the stuff
they claim they could do
when I was that age I could but I cannot
now yo what he's trying to do is trying
to do
that we've explained the uh Rules of
Engagement with the uh 48 thank you yeah
so once we hit 50 what will happen is uh
you know you could make a lower play
retro game then we'll give you another
Community wait a second all I gotta do
to get the 50 to get you to play games
yo fifty percent hey guys
hey guys I want you I want you to work
out some wild Evil game that we used to
play back in the days and get attic to
play yeah that'd be safe see but we are
doing uh a poll uh what Laura plays a
retro game oh okay and it's up to them
and King you know they love him
I don't know these attic the these
addict online polls don't tend to be on
the up and down
[Laughter]
that was the greatest uh moral
upstanding yeah
who's back there is it independent
officer yeah
but of course we have the most technical
gaming Lord the solo game of hills for
the single player selfish experience and
also the substradamus the Lord of
clarity and Lord patreon of the iron
bank my man Lord sorry for now we doing
sir oh good good I'm doing good
exhausted haven't shaved you can tell
what happened
the unshaven I remember that remember
that yeah I remember the first time he's
the the boss from Dead or Alive one dead
or alive one yes
so that you know I've been good uh you
know when you get you get the new toy in
the house you're just messing with it so
I just downloaded like oh like a pause
you want to try every single game see
how it runs and just throw everything at
it to see how it runs in it it hasn't
hasn't filmed me yet except for that
Spider-Man for whatever reason it just
keeps hiccuping but I forgot to tell you
what's that so the power brick for this
thing it's crazy bro it's the size of a
steam day chill is it mine's that big
too yeah it's like the size of a steam
deck bro what's that big pause yeah that
we we're like
the power bricks
he literally said power brick and I said
mine is too oh really yeah I see what
type of Sunday this is it's gonna be one
of those it's a spicy Sunday but yeah so
yeah just having fun like you know
trying out a whole bunch of different
games or whatever you know running
beautifully so I'm very
[Music]
um but it's funny because shout out to
Game Pass PC for a while long for sure
it defaults to the PlayStation
controller as the default could jump
really I was like nah come on man really
it's straight up defaulted to the Dual
sense and I'm like what what the hell
like just stupid little thing you just
go into you go into the options and
change it but I'm like really really
interesting on a Game Pass PC so yeah
that was it um I played a little bit of
it running beautifully
um I'm excited to play that game because
it just I know y'all don't talk about it
in more depth a little bit but it just
seems like it seems It's that middle
ground of like it's it you know if
you're not
the dude that's into souls and can and
you know can beat these bosses or
whatever kind of gives you more options
to be able it's a little more forgiving
is what I've been hearing
um
crazy I heard that but apart from that
like yeah it just seems like you know it
has my Parry in there it has it has the
the the the the whole sort of historical
Chinese studies and stuff like that
Dynasty Warriors yeah you see that's the
thing right we never talk about the
muscles if we don't play the moves
apparently correct but for us Dynasty
Warriors the original dinosaurs fighting
fighting games
and I remember that was the first
fighting game and it was it was an
automatic thing but when yeah it looked
beautiful in that place oh yeah remember
the channel five there was there were
moments
right and it was like I forgot how you
did it it wasn't an auto move or
something like that
what it was is when you hit the same
button and I hit the same button it
would initiate that a combo of sorts
and it was like I don't even remember if
it was just for show or or if it gave
one the advantage over the other
whatever the case may be but that was
the first time in a in a fighting game
that we saw that sort of very fluid
movie like back and forth oh my God yeah
and then after that they didn't follow
up with it they didn't care about that
thank God for for Soul Calibur but they
they didn't follow up with that in a way
that I think they should have because
that probably it probably wasn't a
commercial success because no that gave
that it was a great you know what's
funny you said that I had to Maddie
loves Dynasty Warriors as it is today
but young he didn't know it was a
fighting game he was like I said bro it
was a fight it was the first entry he
was Googling it or definitely Duke he
was like yo this looked kind of crazy
and I was like for its time it was right
up there with the tech-ins and the thing
as far as the list yeah for us for us
but I I agree it could have been it
could have been good successfully
because they made the No No
but we the tekkens and stuff like that
kind of overshadowed it there was a
little bit more fluid but this was a
little niche game yes fighting game
Dallas was really good but the
difference is
these are generals that was commanding
large exactly all the armies these are
historical figures wanted to change
these guys into what they were actually
doing yeah straight you know Romance of
the Three Kingdom stuff or whatever yeah
man yo honestly the PlayStation one
fighting games they have some stuff on
there
remember you guys remember star
Gladiator remember that star Gladiator
yo art of course a bloody Roar yeah
Capcom was on their thing though on
there yeah they came out oh my god when
they did that move you knew you were
done yeah the super moves yes yeah man
yeah so that uh I'm excited to play more
of all along you think we're ever going
to get a Renaissance of fighting games
back I mean it's like this year this
year looks like a special year for
fighting games if that Mortal Kombat
drops as well because we're looking at
Street Fighter Tekken Mortal Kombat I
think I don't ever think we'll ever get
a Renaissance again you know why and I
say this
only because the online doesn't give you
that same visual feel of and I'm doing
it right now subconsciously and I just
saw myself doing it looking over your
shoulder it's not the same as an arcade
it's not it's like I'm gonna put this
working on this area yeah whatever game
it was yeah we would have to be in the
FTC like fighting tournaments to get
that feel again
that's my main
news
the boss that'll be crazy yeah so yeah
and that's the thing though we're just
not getting you know we we have all the
stuff from Arc system works and stuff
like that those things are great but
people aren't taking the risk for
fighting games that they are you know at
least in a bigger space like in this in
the Indies face you saw the fighting
games with like the with the horses like
the whatever fighting herds them
fighting herds and stuff like that they
was they were there's some Primal Rage
of course but that was like a big game
for the time yeah I was up there in
terms of like because of the motion
captions well not motion capture it was
yeah but I don't know what technique do
you think the reason that they made so
many headed Fighters back then is
because they're coming off the hype of
the arcades and then yeah with those
initial games didn't sell well kind of
kind of like validated okay these ones
don't do well so like the Mortal Kombats
like those ones are the ones that
carried on and when you look at the
PlayStation one generation that along
with the racing games were the ones that
was like oh my God I have the arcade in
my house yes so you could do that with a
fighting game you could do that with a
racing game so that was a big deal to
get that in the hospital like wow it's
even better and I have like I have like
uh pre-rendered Cinemas and stuff like
story mode
we just had to end it with all every
character and they introduced Steve in
my opinion like the the sub boss and the
secret character yeah remember you were
like yo you play as your man then you
got the sub boss that's just for your
man that you beat him then you unlock
him and then you get you get a cinema
and everybody got a distinct Cinema to
the gate like it was mind-blowing for
his time with them yeah
I forgot uh skill tickets Drive is next
become game pass
my joint is ready
fgc coming back that was true yeah
this is the yeah it's gonna be a good
year so that's been it sir yes sir and
of course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the access gamer the prophet of
Xbox so I mean King of the statues who
demands nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
fraud alert movement
beloved Lord King how are we doing sir
all right I'm doing great I gotta start
off with something that I was supposed
to do last week that I didn't do and I
like to apologize to my friend green
mason okay now online you know we all
meet people online I met some of my best
friends online and a lot of times when
you're a working person uh you know and
a family person or whatever a lot of
things take your time so your video game
time is really like your precious time
factual the fact that we are online we
don't really get to go out and meet
people so the people that we do meet
become our uh real circles you know um
sometimes you may never meet uh Tom 32
32 across the country but you play uh
games with them every night and you'll
look forward to that interaction and we
lost a a dear friend that um I've known
for I think eight years and his name is
Knox uh we used to play Destiny oh no
and yeah so you know um he's like part
of our destiny crew and you know he
unfortunately passed away oh no put the
question to the chat for knocks you off
but um you know he was somebody that I
met on Destiny and lightfall was
dropping and you know Mason and I we
were trying you know just to gather up
the whole crew so you know we started
doing it because you know it's a college
course type of thing we we just found
out that our friend passed away oh man
wow but on a greater note on a greater
note
um I tuned in to Virtual legality
and my heart you know yeah I had Joy
when I saw him and then just listening
to him talk is the reason why he's so
successful I you know I listen to him
waiting for him to talk about the ABK
deal because you know it's like you know
law for dummies and he and he teaches me
as I go along so I want everybody if you
haven't subscribed to Hogue law virtual
legality go over there you know
subscribe to him a great do very in this
in this FTC ABK crap he will break
through all the bias crap yeah he'd be
exposing even at the top yeah the top
industry uh titles on it sometimes he
was supposed to like hey this is not
actually accurate exactly that's what I
like about it so you know great to see
that now last night I know a lot of you
guys are trying to figure out why didn't
do combat talk like last night with
John's Bones Jones uh fighting this dude
off the shelf right so no no he's a
champion but he clearly
um
the wildest thing about this is they
show I'm watching the dude build up I
would lose all my money right I'm
watching the dude trained for Johns and
and he has trained uh Fighters coming in
uh small Partners anytime fighting them
and the next foreign partner come in and
he's got my owls and rounds and this
guy's sweating he's an animal he's a
beast bones will never be yeah
my money would have been gone because I
would have been I would have bet with
the Beast like nah you know I don't know
about Jones this might be the time yeah
right no no he ages like fine why bro
the man is incredible so
um shout out to John's uh we was talking
in the background hopefully he can keep
his his nose clean
quite literally literally
but you know it is what it is sometimes
like I was saying before uh you got to
separate the atrocities from the art
yeah
that's what I got to do with this guy
but I saw Creed last night and let's go
r r with the Lord's Tuesday at 5pm I'm
going to tell you about it uh if you
would like to wait until then I would
suggest you listen to what I gotta say
but uh cocaine Biz out here tearing up
these streets yeah I gotta watch that
man everybody keep saying good things I
keep hearing about it everybody that
sees it says thank you uh for giving me
you know the advice to go see it so if
you got any cash you want to go see a
good movie go see cocaine beer and also
go look at loads of uh
um I don't know with the Lords and you
can hear me and addict talk about it now
but I was playing this week though um
I was going to say uh I do have the
episodes of Chainsaw man going up
periodically I think I got two up next
week all of them are uh they're
scheduled uh but what I am going to do
because I haven't what they just
released an hour episode of Attack on
Titan yeah and it's like it's weird
they're doing like a part a final part
three episode two so uh I'm going to I
think I haven't watched it yet so I'm
like at this point I'ma just look I'm
gonna just watch it at the computer and
post it on the patreon so if people want
to see my library and apparently it was
a crazy episode people were tagging me
on Twitter saying King needs to get
caught up so he can watch that godliness
to happen yes
you definitely need to get caught up
out of pocket he said John cocaine banjo
CJ you gotta fight
you know what's crazy the fact that this
man be doing all that kinds of crazy
stuff and he's so talented that Dana
can't you can't do anything
right because it's like it's clear and
he people used to say it's because he's
young but now he's getting up there and
he's still taking off he's getting up
there and he hasn't fought in in a while
he's at heavyweight dude this the guy is
the guy is guys he's one of the best UFC
fighters because I that when I watched
UFC that's when he was at his Reign like
when he was fighting vetor or and stuff
like that run through the light
heavyweight Rampage showing gun but
remember when he destroyed Vegeta like
he ran through the top dudes like people
who were destroying the car and he beat
them and he more than likely more often
than not he beat them at their own game
he really
that they know this is the thing though
he really I guess he would have loved to
have been able to beat him because
he he knows like he was like yo this
dude is great and he has the opportunity
to like if he was not if he wasn't Jon
Jones right and he was more basically if
he was more like him and more humble
quote unquote yes he would be the
champion everyone looks up he would be a
bum and nobody remember his name oh
that's a truth
are you advocating the use of powders
the only powder that I'm using is
focused it's definitely good for you to
focus so you need to focus on this focus
and start focusing on what power he's
using yeah Lakers played in the chat
y'all Lord make sure you use that get
that 10 get that Focus
I'm drinking last night I don't think he
was on Advanced
I think last night he was on focus and
he was focused on his tasks and he did
exactly what he was focused to do
and you know anytime any given Saturday
night it can go down so yeah shout out
to her I don't know how long she's gonna
hold it but hey quick quick out continue
so the games that I've been playing uh
downloaded the devil had Destiny since
last year and couldn't wait
I jumped in there and the the new moves
is um
it's pretty good it's pretty dope um the
place is pretty dope uh I just don't
like a couple of things I know we're
gonna get to that part we're going to
talk about it uh we was playing fortnite
and but the thing that we got a chance
to do yesterday if anybody came out and
saw the community stream oh yes you got
back to wrestling yes oh my God
yo attic fit right in like yeah right
right he was resisted at first yeah but
he see where the fun hit continue I love
when he when when Saul was just keep
beating him with Bret Hart and addict
said man if you don't get the F off me
and adding addict turned it around and
he's just started getting them and then
you get him [__] you know now I got you
now
when you start doing with the deuce
don't finish it when you start getting
his counters down yeah he like yeah you
ain't gonna just bully me like how you
I know when you got something yeah you
get quiet yes because like before that
he's talking he's trying to distract you
and then once he aha
gets real quiet he starts to
methodically do the things he's doing
but you know that's a funny thing
because you we all fall into the same
habits of where we play Yo how did you
how did you manage to stand up that
ladder quiet nobody said it cause you
try to win the baby now you
gonna I was like yo this ladder is
linked to the intelligence rate of our
character trying so hard to be able to
hit people with them like it wouldn't
let me hit anyone with that I was
getting so frustrated I was like there's
got to be button to let me hit him
beside the upside the head with this one
they're pulling things from under the
ring yeah I didn't know how to do that I
never figured out that oh I know I
figured that one I figured that was lb
that was lb so the same way yeah you go
to when you outside the ring then you
start dragging stuff like then you can
pick the chance you could pick the
ladders yeah it was lit it was lit yo I
gotta say because I don't know remember
the one from the year before or they it
took two years off it was supposedly a
trash fire and I don't even know what yo
crap from 22 on
yo they it they kind of went back to the
essence of what I remember from the
hockey games in terms of control scheme
yes it plays like a fighting game yeah
it's intuitive that way and but but the
difference is that now like you know
with all the Pomp and Circumstance and
you have like the the show of a
wrestling show is as much a part of the
game now as it as as the gameplay is and
for us back in the day you know we had
to make some concessions with the flash
when it came to the N64 games like they
tried with the intros and whatnot but it
wasn't this but the gameplay was so much
like a fighting game and that's what
really Drew Us in and it feels like now
they finally have it in terms of the
gameplay with the wrestling yeah plus
with all the other stuff yeah and then
the thing is me and King was talking
about is that you know we we part of the
tradition is you watch those intros your
character they have we have been away so
much that like I'm seeing Ultimate
Warrior at 60 frames moving down the
ring like all interest was never 60
frames I'm
[Music]
yeah no well you know that uh also
um been getting ready for my switch
you know waiting for the Zelda um
and I had a huge debate last night
just privately and it probably wasn't a
debate it was just a talking to yeah on
um some VR stuff so yeah I'm
anticipating that I gotta clean my Jets
because I'm watching people have fun
with certain vrs so I gotta you know
cool my Jets and just hold off I want to
discuss
yeah but um
oh what's going on we can't pass how
many um I think they said it was uh how
many million of people played high five
Russian purchases two million or
something like okay
you Milly rocking on any block okay but
but you know it's uh it's beautiful it's
beautiful when Games come out and you
know they put the numbers out you know
I like that and um shout out to you know
Microsoft doing a thing you know and
we're about to you know cause a rap it's
about you can't wait for us I can't wait
you know I'm having fun with Game Pass
right now okay okay let's see We Do It
Let's see we do it dude real quick I
want to uh shout out Lord Sinister
yesterday man the Lord's you know what
I'm saying when you get a chance to rock
with our brother with the wrestling on
the community stream it's all love
brother I'm glad we talked it out
everything is good you know it's love we
used to do that oh Shadow five back in
the crib we're gonna do it we're gonna
do it we're gonna get Kai we're gonna
get it I enjoyed it like I can't say I I
actually really enjoyed it yeah
I was talking to uh Tyler and I was like
that I was like damn game make me want
to play the campaign
oh that's the fever the sheistiness I
gotta learn how to play it because it's
certain little things that I want to do
I mean yeah I climbed out the ring as as
Goldberg you know we cheer to rock on
the Rock got out yes oh yeah the magic
yeah it was it was lit but shout out to
sin man we gonna do it again and I think
what is it the new one is about to come
out right yeah
it's so it's so ridiculous that we
waited a whole year we all had this game
last year when it came out yep and we
waited a whole by my request that I've
ever yeah
all right because you got your wrestling
uh we're gonna do it again with the new
one but another Community stream I would
love to do is the rocker blade point
which has to okay I'm I'm okay so I'm
down for that as well so no doubt no
doubt so we all good on that and of
course we have given the gym something
to [__] don't beat Lord Cognito
spreading that realness in the Roman
Idol P not telling what you want to hear
but what you need to shout out to my man
Mr Maddie play Shout out to finally do
talk a little bit about the ABK deal
talk a little bit about Xbox rulers of
going away and all this stuff you know
prior so we talk about that and people
got some weird uh toilet paper hygiene
just shout out to the LSM Community
y'all toilet paper games wow anyway
I will say this about the toilet paper
all right
the argument for the thin paper and king
would know this as a homeowner is you
don't want to clog up yes
so the argument for the for the thin
paper the argument for the thin paper is
valid yeah I get it I don't know about
the aloe vera or whatever okay
I'm I'm I'm a dupe I'm I'm a two-ply
dude
but but there's a caveat the caveat yeah
I'm a wipey man oh okay okay so there
better be wipies there if I could walk
okay so you are that there's no white
piece in your house I know you are nasty
oh man you're a nasty sov so I know I
know for a fact you got them stink
fingers
but but at the same time as a soft says
as a homeowner none of that stuff go
down the total Bowl
that's the thing though I'm not about I
can't I can't be having the the poop
[Music]
this is a fact so do you do if if you if
you plan to own a home
it it's not a choice yeah that's the
thing right you just don't you don't do
that don't do that unless you got 900
every month and you'd never know when
the backup happens and then you in
trouble so learn how to you know use
great bag and hygiene every day you fold
up take out and go out and your dude
wipes dude wipes dude yeah so but the
wipes and everything but make sure
let you grab it up take it out and go
outside that's what you got garbage men
for us you definitely you definitely
don't wipe dry and just keep it moving
around with tissue
anyway
I'll hit tissue button
you think you slick you go to your girl
you turn around with a whole tissue but
yeah
they got Charming Tails oh babe you wow
anyway as I was saying we just discussed
that and uh shout out to the last shout
out to my boy oh we bought this I know
he's a little frustrated you know Texas
shout out to text everybody in Texas
with the storms and everything we got
caught out here so we did get the street
but we're gonna have a monster stream I
want to announce what we got but I gotta
respect either to to to do it so anyway
look out for Last Words we'll get into
that and then yeah for me it's been a
big week finally I'm getting back into
some gaming it's been crazy but
obviously Destiny too late for we will
get into it but a lot of hours of
grinding get ready for the raid try to
get everything that I need to do but I
will talk about the specifics in our
topic and then um finally psvr
man so before I started up I wanted to
try dbo in pancake mode first right and
um P.S yo wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait yes yes how am
I talking about
so all right so you got the box in the
house all right before I'll get to that
I'm gonna get today I just want to set
it up because before I even got opened
about did all that I said let me do dvo
PS5 console version because when you
boot it up it says PS5 or Ps VR2 so let
me try all right before I even get the
video let me do that yo glorious
glorious on OLED it it they even got
more stuff in the background like
because when you play Demon it's like
the background is like an 80s basement
like out of strange things mad stuff
going oh it's glorious it's more more
stuff yes more stuff than other yeah it
is it's nice salute to the con salute to
resolution games this is a fantastic
console Port so uh um XBox
um
some interesting tweets with a lot of
people like y'all would love to have
this on Xbox when they were hitting me
about that so salute to that so all
right now let's get to where you at so
I'm like all right because so I've set
us off last week he had his unboxing all
right let me get the PS4 yeah
ass up if it was like um a hot dog
vendor you know on the corner when you
go get it and they put it in a little
bit now I will admit the uh box
situation did not feel free
it's very thin very very halal food
cardboard situation I gotta keep it real
like I mean this ain't everything but
it's got to be it it just felt like it
just New York City Corner box yeah like
you gave you Corner food and I'm like
damn this is a premium product I'm
surprised it's packaged this way so that
that was you know a little nitpick
sleep please cheaply packaged
very thin yeah it's very thinly packed
very very rippable yeah yeah there you
go yep what'd you go so I've got it
sorry so we'll get there I'm like all
right cool let me set up doing the setup
let me tell you right now the setup is
fantastic I love to say yolks off the
ease I was oh shout out to glasses gay
if you glasses get I was worried with
them a glass again because you know for
my situation with the you know a little
meta price Pro you know you you extend
and you could put on top of your head
and then you you know kind of contract
like that so I was wondering for glasses
used because I felt like that thing
looked like it was going to be you know
all over you so no no they got the front
load button in the front where you
extend it out right it's like a little
Transformer you press the front button
on the right and extend the front part
out then you got the joint in the back
hit the button you can squeeze the back
Joy part out okay then you put it in and
then it has like a little
it almost feels like you know in New
York you know how like the double buses
got that accordion thing in between yeah
like it got this little accordion thing
and it's soft and it it's not intrusive
but it really immerses you but I really
love about it the the lights blocks out
like you You're Gonna Love It King
because you are all about immersion
right so you put the joint in your face
there but the other thing is they got
the headphones see this is for you I
gotta say you got a shopping list oh I
was really upset with that they got the
earbuds right
and what I like is they got the earbud
holder they got an attachment that
connects to put the earbuds like a
little crossbeam bar then they got the
earbuds that go into each joint and they
take those out like a holder then you
put those in your ear over the top okay
now you got the audio you immerse set up
very quickly it it accurately does the
eye still the eye track bro I felt like
I was in bro these are the tests that I
do for a person that has glaucoma I have
glaucoma these are the tests that I do
when I'm in the doctor where they throw
your face they tell you to move your
eyes
beautiful job slowly fantastic the setup
as far as the the orientation of your
face is it correct are you looking do
you get the proper lens Clarity very
well done love this setup right now
let's get to the the
I hate the cord I like I I I'm sorry I
know of course he's gonna say it I hate
the court like it only because it's like
if you're if you're I guess if you're a
standing dude you may be okay but a lot
of times I'm a seated VR dude
bro I got the valari pillow around me
right right then I I got my you know the
chair and if you're moving around and
this chord is long and then on top of
that you can roll over the chair can
roll over the car and then you moving
around and uh
I understand I I just that's my major
nitpicks anyway let's get to the games
so I went for demio VR first right so
started that up
gotta be honest compare all right
graphically yes definitely more things
going on in the Bro super sharp I would
say the pro is on par but this this has
more things it's like it's like more
polygons more things going okay okay
right so you got that and then now the
the thing I didn't like is again maybe
I'm not used to the controllers because
you know how the controls are a little
different so the tracking felt a little
weird maybe it's not off it's just a
little weird to me as a quest owner
right
um the thing I gotta get at them know
that I didn't like is on Quest
I can tilt deep addict knows this if you
play demio tilting the board is critical
so that you can get the proper
orientation Spin The Joint around
I I didn't find no two I went to the
options since tilt is there it's enabled
and I'm using look at everything I can't
tell the boy so if it's something I'm
doing if anybody got it let me know
there is no tilt situation Christopher
Hart how do you tell yeah no tilt is a
because normally a question just press
up on analog and the orientation shifts
it doesn't do that
um other than that just like a little
weird that little weird tracking point
to issue like it plays well it plays
well so that was my neck my neck well I
will say though where the quest does
kind of get them to Pro gets them is not
only you got to tilt
but the mixed reality AR like I could
play demio put on mixed reality and I
can see my house like um remember like
no color like yeah remember how hollow
that's that's what the you know the big
bucks code
remember how we wish they wanted more
polygons
remember where we saw the conception of
of of hololens what it was supposed to
do that's what Pro is doing with dbo in
that space wait a second so yes
it's doing what and how much was the
hololens again
did it ever come I don't know if it was
a commercial no no it was released but
it wasn't is it wasn't like it was they
had a bit for consumers to purchase but
it wasn't a consumer product right yeah
I know it was it at 10. yeah it was
something insane whatever it was but we
the pro is literally the home and buy
like I can make the ball like the board
very small and put it where I want I
could put it on my table in my house I
could move around I got that's that's
what I'm yeah that's what I was talking
about that's that was my questions right
and this was my question I would have
with you last night and then we said
we'll save it to today yeah
I wanted that mixed reality stuff I
wanted that AR stuff I want to be able
to put my headset on first being able to
go and play wherever you want to play in
your VR is huge to me
second
um mixed reality is also a huge thing
because it's a lot of
things you can do with that like we saw
with the hololens uh you know they had
aliens coming out of the wall and
breaching and they came and he was able
to play that I think that's more fun the
the color pass through May seems like
something that's passive right now but
it's I know you're gonna say that the
the the place yeah the quest pro has
color pass through which is amazing but
I gotta I can't front being or even
though Carl what you call it on psvr 2
is black and white pass through right
but it's Chris Clarity bro is is next
level all right but see when you put
your finger bro I could see why my
headsets on on pass through on psvr I
could see the indentations on my fingers
I could see the detail I'm like oh is
this this different with the clarity of
the joint but they don't do mixed
reality correct it doesn't matter if
it's color pass through now I guess the
color pass through is necessary if they
were doing mixed reality right no they
don't have
yeah I mean I said I think that would be
necessary if they had um mixed reality
because they need to see the world and
they need to represent it in its
Vibrance right so the fact that they
don't have it they don't necessarily
need to have a color pasture it kind of
sense to me
um
that was just my questions with it yeah
so was it any game besides Gmail that
you had yeah okay this is the little
debate I have with solve because um
nothing I don't think he went in on
calling about I think it was King was
clowning while you were talking about
the climb simulator yeah so I'm gonna be
honest I I really liked it you liked it
I really was impressed you know as a
person who you know listen the 4K hits
different the HDR hits different when
you start off like you said you wanted a
little dirty conscious whatever they
call you tied up you want a boat
whatever you watching and you see in the
dinosaurs and bro it is absolutely
gorgeous Sky boxes the waterfall in the
top you see and they talk to you call it
a mountain man I grabbed the chalk or
the board I'm like doing a little bit
Yeah my name like like I mean like a
caveman I you know what really impressed
me that I didn't think I would like is
the the actual Bowl Combat First you got
a gr like a bow you grab it from the the
back of your shoulder pull it out then
you use your other hand grab it from the
arrow from the back your shoulder then
do the AIM now the aim look a little a
little weird but yeah right once you
mask once you get used to it and you
pull that thing back you get the haptic
feedback you let that thing off bog I'm
hitting these little Collectibles now
yes King is it's a lot of climbing it's
a lot of clapping they love the cloud
but I will say just the manipulation in
the world plates and you got kicks off
did you get to the little Maracas did
you find the Maracas yeah
I was like yo yo call and then what it
is King you know why I I think I'm sorry
how do we put you to sleep I'm sorry
attic is done so what he would like it
is hashtag just one energy because he
wants true games like and Sony has the
ability with their pedigree and then
this is the potential like to you be
like okay one potential just tell me me
what they got no it's good like I'm not
hating on it like I like no no the whole
reason why is sometimes we realize that
a lot of people don't ever live up to
their potential yeah I get that so but
it has very much it has it has launch
game sort of where it's it's it's the
showpiece is pretty yes and but it isn't
the deepest game in the world
demo but we like that yeah
but it's more than a glorified depth but
it isn't again it's more the showpiece
than anything else right okay yeah 60
FPS the VR hit different show space it's
making my my choices uh harder and and
the fact that you know uh meta lowered
the price on the quest Pro yes
that entice me now that enticed me to
peek my head out the bushes like yeah
what's going on over there yeah
um because
their package for that thousand dollars
is like an unbeatable package the
package yeah it's the wireless and if
you like mixed reality
yeah yeah it's it's an unbeatable
package they literally have a ton of
games and it's just like your library
carries with you I'm already an existing
customer perfect
um it's so it makes it hmm
and then you know I'm hearing the
PlayStation talk so I don't know I'm
still in the middle I'm gonna see what
this Quest 3 does because if the quest 3
does what I expected to do and it's on
par if not uh a little bit better than
the PlayStation uh VR then
knock them out the box Rick glue it is
out of pocket I did not say that Buddha
what you saying in PSV onto is a novelty
my quest Pros are big you out of [__]
everything I've seen it look it's gonna
be what what your choice are the other
day if you want the Sony exclusives you
want that you know I don't know if
they're gonna do that yeah that's that's
the that's the worry the wall Garden the
clothes it's one of those things it's
like it's a gr it's it is such a great
headset that you wish it was opened up
to everything yeah so I was listening to
uh like Jeff Grossman's podcast and he
was talking to I guess he he the dude
that was able to uh jailbreak the psvr
one yeah
he's like it's definitely doable because
if you plug the psvr2 into a PC it
recognizes it as oh oh something has
been connected like a USB thing has been
connected the thing is there's no
there's no firmware the thing is there's
no firmware for it so he was like based
on what I've seen and based on how long
it took me to do the psvr one it'll be a
couple of years but it's doable we'll
see and if you get a team it could be a
couple of months not that we're
promoting these he says solo anyway he
can do a solo for a couple of years but
if you throw some bucks his way we gotta
move on because I'm trying to keep attic
awake
yeah he like he throw this topic all the
way to the bush I could see his face
anyway I would just say I wait next I
will try um what you call it I want to
try no man's sky and Grant come on Sony
Gran Turismo been out for like a year
why is this Joy still seven dollars can
I get a sale can I get it yeah I don't
know if you're not getting this there I
updated to the steering wheel I updated
to the premium pack of PlayStation Plus
sticking there because they got Horizon
forbidden Western there bro can I get a
deal so I can get I don't want to pay
70. I don't understand why they didn't
put uh all the old Destiny stuff in
PlayStation plus they want you to pay
for it just dropped I'm talking no I'm
talking about like the old old stuff
in there I think they made an
announcement something recently they put
it in the PlayStation Billy back anyway
so um anyway I'm done look we gotta go
we got to move on oh he was on sale oh I
missed it a week ago next oh okay
that's what happens when the tree falls
in the forests
let's get this let's get done super
chassis
roll back oh we got 14k hello yeah
15K we can get a console so like we can
get y'all a console if you want that
PlayStation VR too you can get that we
just need to get the 15K right subscribe
share it out because we got what 600 and
some odd people watching right now but
only 190 something like that like button
like button save that Indonesian koala
[Laughter]
Bessie there we go we got General Mack
member for two 28 months actually more
silver oh hell the IOP the Lords it's
the Lord's day keep a respectful Xbox
World Order okay okay
oh this is funny right here
I'll read it again Lord red Jordan but
before one year two dollars super Jack
King bring the PS5 downstairs plenty of
heat that's hilarious
basement then we got akw five pound
Super Chat can you need two series as
toasters to heat the room you have the
best of Two Worlds toast bread and eat
in the new room I heard about this I
want that toaster oh okay is it real Is
that real yeah it's real it's like the
little refrigerator is real yeah
remember the dude that we saw at um at
the the the the
New York City game awards and he had I
don't know if it was a um it was a music
device that was shaped like a series s
oh you're talking about I mean yeah yeah
he had the little um
like almost like a Walkman yeah yeah and
I sing Sarah Bond Pro promo in it you
know I saw that too yeah it's kind of
fire shout out to the queen yes yes
right all right then we have Mark uh
Mark bejeel six uh Euro super uh six
Euro Super Chat uh Sony about to be
exposed this providing King with all the
hate he needs yes King was quite excited
about this very excited about the topics
today lit today
so we have pragmatic Eagle member for 39
months Lord gold thank you brother hit
the like button show appreciation for
the best gaming podcast on YouTube thank
you for a little your peoples are here
okay Lord zedox is in here it's all
about the Minecraft Crocs gang gang
those Minecraft Crocs my way man yeah I
need the four of a gig for sure continue
everybody see him it's nice
[Laughter]
you know what we should have had this in
and actually I'm gonna come over the
list well I'm gonna come with the list
for the E3 or the road to E3 list and on
that list is gonna be if we hit the
Milestone all the Lord's Gotta Wear
crime
you know what's crazy we probably raised
the most money
do it as foolish this but I don't want
to be a part of it we gonna save it for
that and we're gonna make sure
yes go Crocs anyway
Lucius Augustus member for 18 months
Lord bronze much respect to log then all
the small gaming Outlets out there doing
great work the media has really
disappointed me with their ABK coverage
how delicious Augustus man real dude
love the questions what do lovers on in
our um IOP Discord could do
then we have Stitch
remember for two years two dollar Super
Chat make attic play 99 nights yeah
Drake in the 99 nights is is trying to
trying to make me play uh stuff that I
make other people play stuff
I think that game was like bro make King
play something yeah I didn't want you
man
that would be a trash fire though that
game is really really good I'm watching
movies man they won't just be sick all
day
thank you sir wishing you all a blessed
Sunday and you holla at your boy when
that guilty gets Thrive hits Game Pass
yes oh yes
big time
we got Gerald Mack once again remember
for two years two dollar Super Chat was
cocaine bare about John Morant yo
yo
yeah cocaine bad he wasn't toting any
weapons
Discord is in the in the um description
of the IOP so you can find the
information there and it's on that yes
we got free oh Kelly oh dollar Super
Chat shout out to Kelly for changing the
Avatar to the pink Zorro I love that
hilarious dude five dollar Super Chat
have a good Sunday lightfall is booty
cheeks don't buy it until the end of the
year looking forward to re4 remake Game
of the Year by the way let's talk about
life off let's talk about that blessings
and we got Necromancer sale member for
15 months Lord gold Destiny 2 lightfall
did callous dirty yes I agree I agree I
don't understand I agree we will talk
then we have Kate Johnson member for 13
months Lord bronze been a minute finally
cat's in a live show
I did copy that IOP gaming pillow though
shout out to the Lords for this amazing
content thank you buddy
yeah I used to butcher because every
time I think Kate Johnson I think a
basketball player Kevin no no it's not
even that when I copy paste it please
Sean Johnson if I were if I were to look
at the the color in the actual chat I
would I would realize it when I copy
paste it it's just a black and white
thing that's coin is mad y'all get to
the topic jeez stop reading the Super
Chat stop having fun with yourselves and
play about the games you're playing get
to the topic
I never somebody put that in the chat
stop laughing I don't care about your
personal life I can't watch your
personal life if you had fun and I don't
want you laughing
I never understood that Deuce is bad
that y'all having fun and you talk about
playing games so we here for none of
that I would think I would think that's
the reason y'all stay you know what I
mean like this is weird you can get like
straight up news from anybody like when
are you gonna get cotton bud I'm just
saying you ain't getting cotton but from
nobody but us man
yo listen go Focus stop talking about
kicks he get to the topic
Super Chat Game Pass speed does good and
it's only March yes that's right
then we got Robert kellett five dollars
to be chat thanks Cog for the great
recommendations loving mid-style no
you're not calling it that don't do that
do that that's a great man enjoyed my
time with desk two and Gonna Keep it as
it is with the hog leg
you listening to Mr Maddie plays too
much with the abbreviations look I I he
could go do what he want he's not quite
midnight Sons mid-sun we not doing that
but anything else that's that's bad this
is the Volo hog legs
look man do whatever you feel like you
gotta do
results are in and the people have
spoken to the question if Microsoft is
allowed to acquire Activision Blizzard
which factor do you think will be the
most important to getting the deal done
the winner of our three-way ILP poll
deadlock tie
38.8 percent between
Nvidia GeForce now having Xbox games on
their servers
and
I don't care we need to see the smoke
that said brass Smith's envelope
a dead heat salute salute salute you
already know and in last place with 22
percent of the vote was bringing Call of
Duty to over 150 more uh million
Nintendo consoles so salute to that uh
any thoughts of on the uh the Dead the
deadlock that's funny that we get like
we had a real answer and then we get to
smoke and symbol at the top at the same
time oh smoke people stand up man listen
at end of the day Sony's not going to
continue to anything they don't have
fans and we get our fans exactly yeah
exactly cool so I listen I don't if
somebody's not going to concede to
anything and they're just they're gonna
Bank on Microsoft just giving them the
deal anyway without their approval right
if that if it goes through that's that's
my thinking end of the day like they
already the biggest thing the funny
thing is in this last sort of round of
paperwork that we saw whatever they
finally started to acknowledge the
string in cloud and what that means and
going to GeForce now
going to switch in or Nintendo quote
unquote um
probably in some downloadable capacity
and probably some doubt in some Cloud
capacity it shows that they realize how
important that is long term to to how
gaming is going to be sort of situated
so the fact that they that's going to be
important so it for me it's going to be
continuing to show that they're not
worried about competing Cloud
infrastructure it's going to put this
stuff wherever and we're all going to
Kumbaya all the way to the end of time
and that's it so not yet that's my thing
until it until it don't it took until
until Kumbaya is up oh yeah I mean
really if if if you know if if service
is fall to the Wayside then yeah we'll
we'll fill in with the servers you know
the deal go through it's going to be a
nice two years
and then Phil Dominus Maximus
allowed me to reintroduce myself
they're all in position
oh they're 60 seconds
actually uh I I was watching I saw some
Tick Tock videos talking about Order 66
like they don't really have like a whole
lot of like really good videos and stuff
that was taken at that place because
like Star Wars episode 3 is like one of
the only ones but like when they go with
branches of these like Darth Vader
episodes and stuff like that it's like
you don't really notice but that is that
is such a dark thing like it showed like
two or three Jedi fighting to say the
the padawans and they just get shot down
they just genocide
I love it I love it when they're out in
the battlefield and the Jedi is doing
something and the clone troopers look at
each other
you know what's funny it's like some of
the you know some of those clones like
dude this dude get on my nerves thank
God this finally happened
on that um yeah
yeah so we got ducky ten dollar Super
Chat I'm curious why everyone is talking
trash about lightfall do they not
remember the cursive oh yeah that's very
true you've been around sir shout out to
ducky declare the whole East salute and
then we got Gerald Max shout out let's
put the crest in the chat with Joe
Mackle just gifted five IOP memberships
and the recipients have said memberships
were the black Johns yeah not the white
one the black girl we got that one then
we got Zhong ipong I know the white John
yeah that's good
we got dad mod gaming and then we got uh
let me see
okay Asante
recycling them yeah that's kind of crazy
on his show yes two weekends ago and he
just he super chatted and gave him a
membership
then we got tipped whale two dollar
Super Chat have you seen forespoken led
to foreclosure yeah that was some
interesting yeah man I thought it was
supposed to let the world light the
world on fire whoa hold up
well there's the studio and we absorb
them
it was it indicated that it did not meet
luminous let me look up luminous
you know how when your kids say I'm I'm
gonna go out on my arm leave home you
know I'm gonna start my own you know and
even like yeah okay and you know they
can't pay rent they couldn't
come back
yeah so even though they were like seven
to MPD everybody's like oh well it was
successful not according to school come
back home you can't survive out there
you know what's sad about it though and
then they stay CEO or something just
change dude a lot of stuff going on yeah
get over here get over here get back in
here and we gotta let this dude go at
the top of square let's get the dude
that did towable number one
because that's what let's make let's
make Square great again
you know what's crazy though is once
again it I mean obviously it's not an
luminous is is a Japanese team
or I gotta say it don't matter they
Japanese team now yeah
get back in the house get back in the
house you out here doing what you put
that first pick it up man if you get
back close the door on him Jim yo they
already have it in Wikipedia as it was
[Music]
man somebody save him from himself
listen
[Laughter]
they got Lisa Turtle from from Saved by
the Bell to do the Bronx action it's
like come on man
yo for smoking is gonna be that game
y'all gonna feel this Y'all Gonna feel
it you felt it now
oh man did you see the Traverse I
haven't seen Christopher hosting
anything you messy bro I love it yo hey
man get back in here
you can't be outside alone
I know awareness
this man is literally popping bottles
foreign
like like Horizon forbidden West this is
what this is where they go to die
oh
wow yeah I'm too happy about it too
happy too happy we got Robert Keller two
dollar super tap for spoken actually got
them foreclosed fam yeah
foreclosure
yo shut his Michael he's doing too much
he's off the Focus right now after
foreclosure
came back
you are out of five it is it is a
product because they were like seventh
MPD so I thought it was good but yeah
anyway moving on because ammunition
let's finally get to our next topic
who's been extremely patient that whoa
long sir shout out to Lord addict
whatever it's cool I'm just I'm just
grinding catalysts why I know you play
games you've learned to deal with our
foolishness with you yeah we can see the
screen we can see the screen in the back
too it seems like your your screen's
projecting on another screen while
you're playing you're doing snitching
yeah fine I don't care for snitches no I
salute to you so uh shout out to eye
Lords you know what I'm saying getting
that uh code provided right so uh he was
able to review whoa long and then shout
out to Lords and gaming Dot
what's the best
the biggest collaboration we've ever
done like at the same time facts shout
out to the Lord addicts setting the
trend organizing the whole thing and
then the Articles the guides this man's
shout out to Lou Boo because y'all gonna
know the name but enough about me talk
about this game now that it's out in the
wild you know you put you had your
review but what's your impressions man
um I actually think that
you know I've always felt like team
ninja has good Concepts but they never
execute anything well you know it's
always like they're always
want things short and they all their
games you know is this game
on those calibers like a from software
game I would actually say yeah well it's
definitely not there with like sakuro
and Eldon ring but I think this is one
of the first games I've seen team ninja
do where I could see I could definitely
see them getting to that point
eventually as long as they're nurtured
correctly they learn from their mistakes
I could see Tim ninja delivering just as
good games as from software but the
problem is is you know they always miss
miss something big and I feel like
they try to they try to be too much like
sekro but didn't do anything that that
was better than Sakura like you know
they the pairing they got on there but I
would say that Perry and Sakura was just
on another level like to this day I
don't like pairing but sakuro may be
open to it and I because I prefer just
to Dodge I prefer just to roll out of
the way remember uh you know when it
comes to uh demons uh Dark Souls I I
wouldn't I didn't hide behind a shield I
just rolled out of the way uh you know
that that's generally where I stick to
but you know I'm looking at this game
and uh the boss thematics is pretty good
I will say this is an easier game than
most from software games I don't think
it's uh excessively hard besides
lubu's a pain
there there's a couple people that
definitely you don't want to mess with
uh they're a lot of the people that fly
uh when they're flying they're very hard
to hit they're very hard to you know
predict they're extremely unpredictable
you got some teleporting uh bosses in
this game I will say that the co-op in
this game is all God awful
I don't expect it to the way it is it
doesn't really you know how like well
first off you know uh you know how
in redfall let's say I jump in your game
called yes and only yo stuff carries
over
well the way me and smooth was doing it
I don't know maybe we were doing
something wrong
but we would jump into a game and it
wouldn't carry ether for either of us oh
no none of y'all stuff it's it's like
you're playing a chapter individually
that's not in any of your stories oh no
so like you would start that mission
over from the beginning and you would be
able to play the whole thing
but when you went back to your
respective game the progress didn't
carry over oh no I need you to beat
these bosses for me
I need to be carried so hopefully they
fix it you know
I I prefer the finger system oh you like
the Elder rig figurative well no no I
don't like it but at least when I when I
call for backup well I didn't call for
back when I help people in Eldon ring
they it carries over to their story you
know this one is like oh you good you're
good you don't need no help yeah and I
think that's a big mess but you know I
will say even a lot of the
the hiccups I I do think Ninja Theory uh
1930 team ninja still has a really big
issue with overwhelming you with with
equipment you know in the review you
definitely go check out the review it's
on the channel
I I scrolled down all the equipment for
like a minute literally full blown
scrolling down for like a minute
and I just think that's too much it's
like I'd prefer you know you make it a
little bit
overwhelming me with equipment always
like makes me not want to like really do
it because most of the time I'll just go
to gravitate towards like one or two
things and I'm just gonna stick with it
uh you know there is an upgrade system
on here one thing I like is there
there's a Trad Smog on here nice like
that uh that doesn't cost you money oh
it's free that you can just use wow
that's my general uh exception you know
and first off shout out to you know uh
uh we were provided review code like
Colin said by
um Namco I think that's what they're how
do you pronounce
and Microsoft yeah yeah uh by both of
those I'm not trying to pronounce that
that company I you know what's funny
what I was writing the review I had to
call Anchor Man I'm like yo pronounce
this well that's the studio because I
didn't want I I didn't want to not
pronounce it for the review correctly uh
but you know it's it's a good game I I
think that it's definitely worth an
experience you know it's in Game Pass
you know I see a lot of good feedback in
the uh around the industry I don't see a
whole lot of people not liking it I
think you guys will enjoy it now
obviously if you don't like these Souls
type of games
then you should probably stay away from
it but I do think that
it's more accessible because you could
take up to two people with you
uh there's a lot of options that you can
have it do you have any questions yeah I
have some specific questions on one
shout out to D harm Fred he said you're
supposed to salvage the equipment that's
what he said he's supposed to do that
yeah but that that's cool but once again
they're still overwhelming me with the
equipment okay just because I have to
you you yeah you could Salvage them and
I had no real issue upgrading stuff it's
just dude it's like just reskinned oh
you know now you got a three star
instead of a four star uh there is you
know five-star equipment that you can do
after post game uh there's a lot of
optional stuff I actually did a lot of
the optional stuff in this game uh
because they actually told me what I was
gonna get oh wait a minute
I almost 100 of the whole game that's
crazy
you don't chase book bags like what was
it these are not Collectibles it's
actually gear that's actually relevant
to what's going on
mmm you know that you can get like the
dragon scale armor uh they eventually
start having you fight like people that
you would generally fight with against
as like little sparring matches and
it'll be strictly one-on-one like it's
got a lot going for this game but it's
like I said performance is God awful
for the most part I I was fighting the
last boss
it crashed two or three times wow yeah
series X but I've been told it's just as
bad everywhere else you know I think
we're getting to the point where these
devs are being too comfortable releasing
games that have too many issues like and
I'm I'm to the point now where it's like
Playstation Xbox Nintendo steam like if
these games don't consistently work in
this mad performance issues rip these
games off your stores
are you gonna rip it off a game pass you
know listen let's talk no it doesn't
matter if the PC pass it should work PC
games has been like bad bro I don't game
over on the master race though but you
would think like no like the
optimizations like this again the
Spider-Man issue but they've been
this one works great
um in terms of so far performance I
haven't had anything crash on me but I
haven't played very much so yeah
shout out to them for making one one of
the hardest first bosses I've ever seen
yeah I was going to ask you that because
first book yeah I'm hearing things about
the first boss and I want to give
context because I remember obviously you
were playing it you know during the
review period and you were like oh man
like I don't like parrying you were like
I don't know like you were I've never
seen you visibly angry and I'm like oh
no hold on don't sound like it's gonna
get him yeah
like straight up [__] almost yeah like
like but yeah you were definitely not
happy and you I was like oh yeah like he
gonna like and then something clicked
and you hit me like a day later you like
[__] I get it I love it if I happen but
but I want to focus on the parents but
what a focus on the Parents game okay
the wildest boss because I listen he hit
me up in this damn lubu and so the
wildest boss made you like it
yeah because it was a well choreographed
fight it was unique I've never fought
anyone like like when you fight lubu the
reason that he's so hard is because the
game is designed for you to stagger
enemies that's how it's designed right
um when you stagger lubu because when
you stagger them you do like uh
something called a fatal blow where you
pretty much stab them and do like a huge
amount of the damage first off that
damage is pretty much half what you do
to anyone else second off when you
stagger him the first time he just gets
thrown off his horse you don't get to do
it the honor of fighting
he fights you on foot right and you have
to stagger him again to do massive
damage too and it's like I said it's not
even massive damage and then guess what
after you may have staggered him one
time on foot dude jumps back up in the
air gets back on his horse and keep in
mind during this entire time his horse
is running around in a circle on the
battle and they'll be times where you'll
you'll be fighting him and you because I
said in the in the tips to fight him be
very conscious where that damn horse is
what the horse doing when he running
around you'll be fighting him and and
Luba will jump up to do like an
unblockable about her I got you I got
you I'm about to get this
horse hits me oh he's summoned the horse
yeah no so the horse never leaves the
field when he falls off his horse he
runs around in a circle
all right so the first time attic got a
chance to meet uh lubu was in the record
of Ragnarok that's on Netflix and you
know talked about it no I've played
every Dynasty or I've also this is the
legendary
he's out of control he was out of
control in that anime
and from what I'm hearing he's out of
control here yeah all right so I just
want to back up a second so because I
met I remember you said yo I'm a guy
that plays those games I roll I really
don't like parrying so like the lube it
was it the lubo fight that got you to
say okay I'm into Parry because you
don't like pairing and then you like
completely 180 he's like [__] I love the
game and I get it now
the pairing in this game's okay when you
parry unblockables but it's horrible
when you parry regular boots it's just
horrible it doesn't feel good it doesn't
look good would you parry on Checker out
doesn't matter who you parry what you
parry Everything feels good they did a
lot of good job when it comes to making
sure that that game runs fluid when you
pair yourself you see the the white
flashes going on like you're clashing
swords you hear that that store clashing
going on you see it pop uh the the
Stagger bar going up the reason Sacro is
my favorite from software is the
attention to detail on that game it's
absurd I like Sacramento and I like
elderly
because sakuro
the last Boston secro the only other
boss I've ever there's like three bosses
in my entire life I fought that gave me
more trucks
it was the the last Boston Sakura he
gave me issues uh because he he
ridiculous like he was fast he kept
switching swords switching weapons
switching stance jumping up throwing
lightning at you and it was it was a
battle of attrition because he had so
much hell and lukewig off of bloodborne
this is the first DLC boss that dude I I
literally right quit I I went I went
looted it's on my channel I went crazy
fighting that dude now you know uh there
there there's a couple bosses I would
say it costs from uh bloodborne uh he's
just as hard but
lubu is real Lupu is the definition of a
from software fight so is it just that
it was the lubu fight that made you then
follow up in general is good but lubu
really
by the time I fought lubu because you
know once you really start getting the
timing down on everything you understand
the fortitude and morale system yeah you
understand you know exactly where you
want to level up the biggest criticism I
can get for this game is it has stealth
mechanics with no stealth dedicated
button so I would have to like like
pretty much like barely push my
controller up just hoping it doesn't run
too fast like on secro you just you hold
one of these buttons and he'll Crouch
right like you would on Assassin's Creed
but on here you just have to like walk
slow but the problem is is there's no
there's no button to make you walk slow
so you have to like barely tip it up and
sometimes I just be getting hit out of
nowhere uh lady Maria was a good fight
in bloodborne but I wouldn't say she was
hard okay so besides that then you start
to get the systems and the last question
I have before I opened it up was like
the um the morale system right because
it was like you said there was like two
systems that you didn't understand at
first and I guess the morale if someone
beat you everybody got a number and then
if you they beat you they just go up you
go down or whatever or something like
that like what was the two systems that
confused you to finally put it together
besides the period the spirit system
kind of confused me a little bit in the
morale and fortitude system what a
morale system is is every person on the
map got a number uh you know bosses
generally have 20. that's generally boss
some have lower lower boss uh you know
the earlier bosses baby got like 18 but
generally they're 20. lupus that has had
20. but so what would happen is
let's say I'm five
I pull up on someone that's 10. go here
10. you're pulling up I might as well be
fighting a brick wall oh yeah I'm seeing
that dude because the higher that number
is the difference in that number the
worst time you gonna have uh now when I
can't if I do kill that 10 then I'm a
five I'ma probably go up one or two okay
because I killed such a strong opponent
gotcha uh the fortitude system is
there's these flags it's throughout
every map there's big flags that I
thought was TR uh you know fast travel
system yeah I was wrong
and then they're smaller flags that is
just smaller Flags in a real point now
what it is is for every small flag you
get one for every big flag you get two
sometimes they two one you know uh two
two uh four to two systems okay uh so
let's say I get the 42 system I die at a
level 20. you know lobu killed me sit me
straight to hell I come back level two
uh I I died I don't come back as a level
20 or more out I come back whatever my
fortitude number is
[Music]
you can generally get in every map you
can get your four to two system to 20.
so you can they set it up to where you
can fight the bosses on equal grounds
nice and then but you have to go look
for the flags okay but you got to go out
your way and look and do extra stuff so
that yeah they actually make it even
better because 20 is not the max but
none of the bosses have a 25. 25 is the
max so you could theoretically get 20.
go grind the other five and fight the
boss at an advantage Oh okay that's
what's up
they put a lot of systems in the system
it's in the game to make it more casual
without taking away from the core of
experience and that's what I like when
developers do they look at something
like look
this system likes this people like this
we we don't want to interrupt like it's
like from software with the you know
difficulty setting we don't want to put
a difficulty setting in it because we
know our casual audience don't want this
okay so what we're gonna do we're gonna
make we're gonna make a fortitude system
to where if you get all of those flags
and reward you for exploration you're
gonna come in there and you're gonna
body everyone but the boss but if you
want to you know make yourself a
challenge you can go in there and fight
a matter too go ahead you'll probably
get clapped but you can try that that's
a good explanation that's what I have to
know absolute man this is good stuff
we'll open it up because I didn't get a
chance to play I've been doing VR I've
been doing so much other stuff and I'll
probably play it tomorrow but I was
gonna ask solve
um do you get a chance to play or you
still gonna it's on the list
yeah like I said I just I I installed it
I managed to go to the uh create a
character did that and I played a little
bit okay it is yeah
I sent you a picture of myself I'm
looking good out here I'm looking good
out here but you ain't got an afro
that's true
I'm talking about my Afro uh you know
melanated brothers that's true
is decent I didn't I didn't they don't
have a Caesar per se they have just
balls kind of balls
join us join us I joined you join me I
still have a hairline
I don't like the McDonald's sign you
know
don't be bragging about your gifts yeah
yeah so I did that yeah it definitely
follow Queen challenge
options are nice yeah it was fun I don't
I generally don't get into the like the
minutia of it because it's just like
yeah do you want to slant the eyes a
little bit do you want to turn them down
do you want to do this it's too much
like that I just I tend to go with the
with the most you know I I like to mess
around a little bit to make them
generally look like me with all that
other stuff but if you love that stuff
it was funny I don't care about none of
that stuff most of the time I go default
or uh
and randomize it because to me most of
these games I put a helmet on 10 minutes
later and I never see it you've never
seen it anyway yeah but attic you are
probably default character like let's be
a book right it's like you get a
character it's default and all you gotta
do is add a beer and I'm like oh that
but I I don't I I don't I don't look at
my character like ever now I care more
about like like the the gear I might
wear you know and exactly how that looks
but as far as like the way my character
looks like I've I couldn't I've never
cared about the way in any game I've
ever played even when even when like it
matters like I forgot that my character
on on Titanfall was an EXO
yo my joint on Destiny when I took the
helmet off I was like oh yeah I forgot
I'm I am awoken yeah
so yeah so that um yeah so that it was
cool to see that I just jumped into that
initial part like I said the game was
running really well I didn't have any
issues so far
um what I do like I'm a Parry dude like
I for me I love staying in the pocket
and seeing how much I can Parry
encounter that I think all the way back
I think it must have been like Street
Fighter Alpha one where I was like ah
well hold up I could I can flip this
around and turn it around and then
obviously tech and as soon as I figured
it out in second it was yeah it was a
problem I think the reason I never
jumped on pairing like that is because
like some developers do pairing really
well but some are like really
inconsistent with it works correctly
right and I think that I learned at a
young age after trying these bad games
that that have bad pairing systems I'm
like yo let me just dodge yeah like I
don't got to worry about getting a hit
if I roll out of the way did you did you
find it unintuitive addict that Parry is
a button unto itself and just not
because I've seen a lot of games where
pairing is a tap of the block button and
then full on block is you holding that
button where this you have a the B
button is the Parry right I think that's
the second one I can't remember I don't
remember how the second real bumper is
yeah but it was it was a little weird to
me that full-on block was one button and
then Parry was another one so it wasn't
like it it wasn't it I liked it but I've
seen it in other places where it's both
it's one button and just you tapping it
and it that feels really intuitive
because if you're trying to apply it
boom boom boom boom and then oh I got a
hole Yeah and now it's a flower too yeah
I think I think the reason that they
didn't care like you know uh Advanced
tip to the people in the chat uh there
there's a spell you can get that like
gives you partial your your health when
you hit someone so what I started doing
is like they've really on this game they
want you to to do the the Fatal blows
they're very big on that like when they
when you stagger them and they're
sitting they're like going like this
like they want you to do a fatal blow so
if you pop that that Health move and you
do a fatal blow you get like half of
what you do to them in damage and when
you're doing a fatal blow doing a lot of
damage you can get like what equivalent
with like half a potion with Wood Hill
and you can get that back that's how I
started doing like the in-game stuff
because the right when I when I
staggered them I'd pop that spell go for
a fatal blow and and you know I would
still use potions but not as much
because I'm using that move with the
potions I love the fact that you can
Parry so I mean obviously unblockable
ones but I love the comparing like you
can Parry supers and stuff like that
yeah I love that because again it it
allows you like addict said it allows
you to play the game how you want it
doesn't make force you to play the game
in a certain way you think if I want to
stand there and learn that parry and so
that to me disagree I think it doesn't
allow you to play how you want uh
because they really they demand you to
pair like it's not something in that
regardless that's what your frustration
was because you could roll all over the
place you're not gonna win if you don't
Parry like because when you pair those
unblockables that you do like 10 15 20
of his stagger bar if you hit him that
that's like 50 slashes to get that much
wow okay so it's imperative you do that
otherwise you're a dead man yeah because
the first boss the reason people are
getting clapped the way they are is
because it's telling you in that boss
you are going to Parry this game if you
don't you're gonna have a bad time yeah
I think from what you said
beyond the pairing stuff which I love is
I like the fact that they don't make
there is no there is no lower difficulty
level they give you all the tools and
you and within the game you decide if
you want to make it easier for yourself
or harder for yourself in that regard
like that's kind of what I feel made
Elden ring accessible and that the fact
it's like okay you're not you're not
set on this path and you have no way
forward except just getting good and
beating this you have other ways to go
around and grind or whatever the case
may be I don't know how the grinding is
this early is here but the fact that it
gives you tools within the game to sort
of be able to grind a little bit over
here
I think I'm level 100 and like 10 or
something like that they figure
something out with this way whether it's
it's it's from or is these guys it's
like okay how do we make these games
more accessible where the hardcore
aren't getting pissed off and still love
the game and can play the game how they
want to do it take a chance the 402
system and the marasa it's it's a really
good system I I would say that that's a
good middle ground that like look you
know you could go in there you could
fight him with like a five or l or a 10
and then you still have a huge
disadvantage or you can you know explore
get uh you know that 20 and then you
know on top of that get the other five
from fighting enemies and stuff and I
think it's a good system a good
balancing system they don't change
anything drastically but they give both
sides something to encourage people to
come in and to give the people that want
that type of gameplay what they want to
yeah yeah so that I'm excited to play
more of it for sure no doubt I'm sorry
solving the king if someone sir
whoa long oh thank God for Game Pass I
knew that's what this is gonna turn into
thank God for game pass because
nothing you said enticed me at all
do not mention that curse word oh [__]
that's a bad word for you yeah because I
remember he he bought that after the
game of the year oh I got to play this
okay but he was like oh no okay but yeah
when I was out in the street in front of
yeah
yo I uninstalled that game so fast I
smeared that when the random dudes in
the street
oh
come on it's such a good game man it
will never be seen I I think it's
pristine clean like
the reason I like like Sakura more than
eldering I love Elder an amazing game
but the sakural fights were so memorable
like I will never forget some of those
Sacro fights no would I never forget
playing a good game oh my Lord clearly
kick his kick team shout out to Elden
ring winning game of the year and being
exactly what they say they were
um that game I would never know I would
never know when you made the ball too
high oh you must Perry I don't must do
anything in Elder Wing I just must win
you don't do anything right and wulong
and circle you just you just uninstall
I took the game out maybe one day I
doubt it very seriously
um that I would go back and play this
game I guess is it like a torture tactic
if somebody forced me to play this game
oh yeah you know we got to get King to
play this then
Cox or the next Community streak is King
speed runs
the only speed you will be so upset with
me playing and dying yeah me just speed
dying yes
um and that no I would not recommend
that for myself but again I was I don't
know I might try this game I it's a it's
a better PlayStation game that's a
little bit more easier
I thought you would be support no I I
purchased that PlayStation Plus it
better pay off it yeah I'm talking about
for what long with the GamePad I thought
this would be it's nice for you guys
it's nice for you individuals that like
this brutal style of gameplay that
repeatedly beat you into submission this
this the BDS DMV
I mean he he's not really like people
like myself that beat this game like
like these type of games there might be
something mentally wrong
these dudes these dudes looking for this
I like games to breathe beat me
I don't want that I want games that are
nice you know that yeah you feel
accomplished in doing stuff I'm at a
point in my life I don't need to be beat
into submission
comes with a whip
like no no I'm good yo you gotta sit
there with the gag ball
that game
literally screams torches
[Laughter]
I don't want any of that and that's all
I hear I hear that all the time like I
saw um what you would call The Angry
Centaur gaming I I saw ACG his joint I
saw addicts joint of course and I'm just
like I feel there's something wrong with
you yo it's funny me and him have the
exact opposite feeling about wolves you
did and it just goes to show
that you you guys y'all y'all are
special people right that can play these
games and can end it and don't allow
frustration to set into a point where it
doesn't it impedes you from finishing
your goal I respect you because like you
said you took a couple of days back and
I remember when you was playing the game
your king I got to get this done I got
to do this I got to do that I won't be
able to do this but I have to do this
and your fortitude and intuitiveness in
these games is second to none be honest
with you oh for sure yeah it's it's a
different free game conquering that's
his name me personally if I was tasked
with this game the task wouldn't have
got done
I would have raised my hands
I'm not into this side
I gotta pass the homework going to
somebody else
that's your preference could you please
take the shot caller off yeah yo
pineapples you know that's my favorite
word pineapples
word
any game that you got to play that comes
with a safe word you don't need this
game
it's a family show a large Intel they
talk difficult game
[Music]
oh what is it a combo around the Eliza P
dude that's gonna be another oh that's
gonna be another one absolutely I don't
really have much to add because again I
had so many other games I was doing the
VR stuff so rollout will be tomorrow
most likely for me but um no everything
that attic is talking about sounds cool
you know I'm like like solve I am a
person who likes parrying you know what
I'm saying I think the the successful
Parry is one of the most satisfying
things in fighting games in game like
you feel like you control the
battlefield you feel you know successful
so we got to see you know because when
I'm with addict though if the windows
are brutal yeah and you just getting
lashed
bruh like that's gonna be roughly that's
tough yeah I want to see the co-op
system I love the good thing is the the
window to Parry is pretty wide there you
go now you're working with me now you're
working with me so I'm like okay cool I
like them around system you describe
except for some of the unblockables
because what they'll do is they'll
change like some people have like slow
anime
and then it speeds up right at the end
yeah yeah and what I like is let's say
they're doing a combo on block board
they hit you multiple times with one
move it's it's it's a move with multiple
hits that's unblockable oh if you get
hit if you if you get hit by the first
one you could still on you could still
pair really make it move
oh because a lot of times in fighting
games that's not the end like you get
hit with the first person you get hit
with the whole yeah you can carry
anything at one point as long as you do
the timing correct oh that's nice but
but sometimes they'll hit you on the
ground and they'll just they'll just go
to time with you on the ground too you
can't do nothing when that happens
you can't do nothing when that happens
some of the things that he mentioned you
know what I'm saying as far as that
we'll see I'm hoping that this is the
Souls game that might get me to mess
around I love the Dynasty Warriors thing
I did hear that if you didn't really
like uh um no see my thing is Alden ring
and them Souls games is too slow
I don't like slow plotting this is
faster yeah like I need to feel like a
ninja I need to move around don't have
me with the dude this isn't a ninja
feeling like game though so this is
definitely more more Neo than yeah it's
me it's it's it's Neo and Sacro together
like and you know I would say they took
some of Sakura's good but you know the
pairing of Sakura was just on a
completely different level like a
completely different level like it's one
of the few games that I wanted to Parry
and and I was hesitant I was hesitant at
first but after you get to some of those
bosses and and said girl if you don't
Parry you're gonna have a bad time you
can still beat him without pairing but
geez they're like no you you know if you
beat this game with my parent we're
gonna punish you that's literally how
they say yeah it's one of them type
Joyce but yeah that's it we'll see I'll
get to it and uh yeah good review shout
out to the amazing team attic and Lords
of gaming.net we got the guys for you if
you struggling with that little boo who
the mother do who I heard that first boy
State teacher you better know how to
Parry otherwise yeah yeah he terrorized
what's his name I I don't remember his
name he's like human something I don't
know but okay though what makes him so
hard is he he's like one of the only
times I've ever seen the second
like he has a second form
and it's like it's like a lot harder
what's funny is I went back and I
watched smooth uh real when he was
playing it it's you could see Sue all
happy he thinks he's about to beat the
first boss died like 10 15 times on him
and then he grows like a giant arm and
and then you can like slowly see the the
happiness of his face and then you
slowly see he realizes there's a second
form
he's just dying in size
I take the judge that's the joke he's
like he's like I beat him he's like wait
what's going on
I'm hearing positive things for the most
part so yeah I will check it out but
that's all I got ladybug I got anything
else did elderly ever come to Game Pass
but they got they announced DLC they
just announced DLC recently
they usually have really good DLC names
and this one didn't do it for me so much
the shadow of the herb tree or something
like that oh well you know the Earth
tree is kind of crazy though yeah yeah
no doubt so that's what we got someone
Super Chat sir yeah we got a couple hold
on a second uh the doctor 63 10 super
chat clears clear as throat attic where
is the naraka blade point
Cog told me to ask you well long collab
just saying let's go oh yes
we have 50 yeah
oh can I get my naraka blade point they
have a wall on crossover by the way yeah
they have a wall
and we could invite
well I mean we can't really invite the
community if it's just four yeah but we
can have other people if people want to
get down if we have the option in the
future yeah but more than come on and
you're down with us yeah I mean we could
play in Iraq though yeah yeah yeah yeah
no doubt we'll get that blade
yeah you saw his face
okay no doubt no doubt oh slow you know
what that work oh who's your mate who's
your baby I'll take yay Sean I take the
Shaolin monk let me know who your main
is in the rocker blade Point slow mo let
me know but anyway I thought Sloan was
playing uh what's we call the division
when they gonna launch the um the the
foreign
[Laughter]
that first one
I love it though
yeah I mean that that's kind of that
that's kind of the thing is the reason I
like that they made that first boss like
that is because sometimes that first
boss is so easy people think oh this
ain't nothing but they're like look like
if you can beat if you can beat that
first boss you could beat the majority
of this game the only person I'll give
you issues little boo like that's you
know that's the majority of the game no
doubt that we have hold on a second
you got tipped whale two dollar Super
Chat yo addict tilt your camera up to
see some TV please
you want to see what you're doing in the
bathroom right the PlayStation VR
there's no filter
wow we can't even tilt me
listen all that money ain't got no tilt
yeah
tilt game up continue then we have a
specter and seven with the 70 uh South
African Rands shout out to you sir shout
out to you Mass Effect love in the
building I see that just in case people
forgot Sakura was originally a new
tencho game Tenchu game but evolved into
second row later and although it may not
have been might may not have the RPG
elements like other from soft games the
action is Stellar yes
shout out to from uh from software too
like you can R you can make an argument
they're one of the best Studios out
there right now oh yeah
in three years well four years they've
had two game of the years Elder ring and
and sakro uh 19 and 20 20. I really want
to see how this armored Core hits yes if
people people are so open on on Elden
ring and they just give armored Core a
chance and then they and they Souls like
armor core in the way the people man
brother that's what's up do not touch oh
mccoying now
if you're from if you are listening into
him don't do what he just said just it's
too late it's done do y'all like please
don't man no but I will say this make
make me a regular channel yes I would
like this game yeah I think that um
I think team ninja kid could make one I
really do um especially especially how
well they've done it and you know I
think Microsoft need to back the truck
up they need they need to to work with
the people that own it I think actually
the people that uh own it is the people
that uh they publish that game the
people that published uh wulong you know
work with them say yo we'll pay for the
game we'll pay for the marketing uh we
want uh timed exclusivity you can even
just do a time to exclusivity he's like
but you know we want team ninja making
attention game and I think it would do
well because let's be here Microsoft
they they don't really have like a
foothold old in that type of gameplay
you know you have bloodborne demon souls
and you know Sony is is low-key securing
more of those deals yeah I think people
go crazy though because they'd be like
wait a minute Y'all Gonna Make attention
game and not a Ninja Gaiden game is wait
you said Sony is uh securing more deals
I would say
the perfect segue into the next time
we'll get there all right let's get this
Super Chat Jonas the dad two dollar
Super Chat uh love the one playing
Hogwarts great Parry yes the one play in
Hogwarts is yeah it's like
it's very good very good that's what's
up Robert actually have a lot of uh a
lot to say on a Hogwarts
yeah that that game was like oh man it's
good I've calmed down on it like
tremendously
we got Robert Kelly two dollar Super
Chat Souls games BDSM get that joystick
guy on wallow
wow
wow do not invoke the name of names
then we have Joe refko AKA flame
remember for two years five dollar Super
Chat well well well it hasn't even been
a week and I see that Cog is playing
other things other than Destiny 2 life
that is not true what happened
but that is not you sir I'm still
playing a little bit of smoke from uh
yeah everybody you know what's funny
what I love about Destiny haters is that
where which Queen was around these dudes
as quiet as a church
we'll get to them I'll get to y'all we
talk he got smoke for y'all I'll be nice
I'll be fair I'll be fine I got smoke
for them he won't he I won't be nice
hold on a second then we have blind
giant 808 two dollars that WWE stream
was hilarious yesterday bro and we don't
even know how to play yet like bro yeah
wait wait till we get a handle of it you
didn't get Whatchamacallit what you
didn't we get more people in there no no
it jumped it jumped in again so I'm
going back
you said I stopped playing that's not
true sir we'll talk about other things
that I have comments on but as far as
plague oh I'm grinding like hell I'm
playing like this
uh did we get the the the patreon
question I got that yeah
Jimmy Valentine yeah I got I got I got I
got it actually has something you guys
would like I think I got my beds on that
I got 723 with only 330 likes police
please
hit that like button and um we can save
this side but cybernetic sloth I can't I
can't we could say idle
instead of chasing them
but I'm a jump protocol because be
afraid of good at it flame with the two
loud Super Chat blink twice [__] I'll
save you gotcha let me tell you how bad
he let me see how thirsty a Warfare play
is the minute he says 80 weakness in
Destiny he's like yes we do content bro
I was like nah I'm good I'm good on you
I'm good yeah all you gotta do is I said
now but I'm having fun still though and
I'm loving the new guy
yo he was trying to push his Warframe
drugs salute the flame try to be an
opportunity or his game but I'm good sir
I'm good thank you though thank you now
we all right over here we all right over
here but continue
and we got stumble back slap five
dollars it's gonna take y'all longer to
read this stupid chat than the amount of
time y'all spent on that Destiny Life
driving in division two really what you
grinding let's look at the contact now
where is it at I'm looking at the
division Twitter account let's see
what's going on with y'all the new thing
coming is the mobile do they got a red
[Laughter]
if you want to go to the dark side
what was it called nature it was called
a dog the dog the dog
you want to go to the dark Zone enter
335. it's Ubisoft gonna either be around
for these division
divisions
and you know what happened as soon as
they get purchased division is going to
go
of the Dog Zone
yo honey see this is how I know division
was definitely this is when I was done
with division with when they took away
to survive a joint
yeah
they went forward without the best
content and they didn't even say yo we
messed up put it back in yeah you're one
of those dudes that can't admit that you
was wrong you know King you know when I
was done with the division at the title
screen oh damn now division two was five
it started off first started off fire
dope you know where I was done with the
division two what it said install
it's so bad this one was dope division
two was good they didn't bring over some
of the fun stuff
I've heard more people talk about card
Rings Call of Duty the laptop they got
raised
you know also what I didn't like but the
fact that you couldn't get like a speed
of something to get you around the city
yeah they hot in St apocalypse and
nobody kid got no vehicle with no
Transportation give me a give me a bite
give me a bite can I get a pedal bike in
division so I can go to the other side
of DC that would have been dope if y'all
could be on the bikes you know your BMX
bikes going down the street
I'm gonna get on my bike and I'm gonna
be like
oh no don't you do that dope that was
dirty that was dirty move it up we're
gonna stop the roasting session
let me see what's next
with each other's joystick yes yes
it's got fast travel
for invoking the name let's play with
each other's joysticks
I hope when I meet slime I scream up
whoa
[Music]
[Laughter]
we only got a couple of weeks left to
get to PAX East so hopefully we can get
this roll D3 but we have 50 and I do
appreciate everybody that has super
chatted purchased stuff uh even
supported us to get us to the space uh
we're working on some great things out
there you know
um we got some stuff that we working on
you know [__] just throwing some good
information on us uh yesterday that
y'all are going to be very surprised and
and enjoy yeah what's what's that to
come we've got some fun things to give
back to the realm so I know yeah IOP
Crocs on the way yeah man if we had some
IOP Crocs
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
questions which we missed before the
topic Jimmy Valentine's salute to the
homie LSM fam out there in Houston we
was chilling um hey guys love the
content in the show if you had to enter
a fighting game tournament where any
character was available to choose who
who are you choosing he's personally
going with Gambit from Marvel versus
Capcom 2. thanks again [__] for the
discussion in Houston you are the truth
have a great day salute you all the
truth as well sir so um yeah fighting
game if you had any gonna enter a
fighting game tournament with any
character available to choose who are
you taking Lord fgc Community let's go
uh I don't play Fighters but I think I'd
play I would choose Jack Ablaze from the
original Fable I think he would he would
have like a lot of original moves that
would be cool to use he like teleports
yeah
and if he if it had like like finishers
kind of like like Mortal Kombat a cool
finisher because Jack Ablaze is just
like uh he just possesses The Mask he
has he's not the actual person so like
you after you beat him he just takes his
mask off and slabs it on his opponent's
face because once you once you put on
that mask he possesses your body okay
excellent Jack Ablaze Lord solve
fighting game Enthusiast so can it be a
fighting game character no just any
character he didn't I mean he just said
it and he said if it was a fighting game
tournament where any character was
available to choose I don't know if he
missed any character every character
from any fighting game probably that's
what I'm thinking so I think I mean but
what but what addicted is kind of fun
though
he maybe he meant that I don't know I I
would say if it's any character from any
game I would pick
it has to be Jason Bourne from that that
Jason that Jason Bourne there's only one
Jason Bourne game it's not Jason Bourne
it's a born something I forgot what it's
called but just he's just a lethal
murderer and he's just murdered you and
everything you know how many different
ways
you'd be crazy if you had a John Wood
versus Jason Bourne yeah shout out to
send us to the chat he said Tekken a
addict got backy I didn't
I didn't like that anime I don't know
why I wanted to like it I wanted to like
it so bad it just wasn't resonating it
wasn't feeling good Bucky I don't know
what y'all talking about and if it's
anime you're like yeah Baki isn't it
fighting it's fighting yeah okay so and
if I'm just gonna pick up the face yeah
fighting good character who you picking
it's got to be Ken I I love Brian Fury I
love King I'm I'm Beast with both of
those guys but Ken Ken is just I can sit
King knows we could sit there we could
sit there at range one Ryu okay for me
Ken for me
yeah they changed them they're really
different he got one of the best music
stages in fighting yeah
yeah he's a beast but King and I can sit
there at Reigns damn near zero and
Fireball each other back and forth it is
it's something about that dude
I have it down and and I'm in the zone
it's like there was a i before before we
got back together and kind of started
hanging out again I was kind of I was I
used to run slip shot with and it was a
thing like do not ever jump don't ever
jump or if you jump forward don't don't
jump just don't jump just don't jump
straight up be aggressive yeah so yeah I
was it's got to be careful
oh that music was all right with the
boat with that kick let's go what you
doing all right so my joint for
um like random wildness
um okay so I'm gonna do random wildness
random Wallace and then fight a good
character real character all right uh
random wildness oh I didn't do my
fighting game character can I can I just
say uh link because he was in SoCal oh
sure that's good I like that that's
really good salute my my random
character will probably be Iron Fist
um
the moment that character's brought up
you don't remember the good days with
them he remembers the absolute one I
would too I would too if if they have
you know uh College Bound ninjas
you actually have ninjas that you could
use but you decided to have the dudes at
the BMX bikes in the backpacks I really
don't feel tracksuit Mafia
no so I I really respect exactly what
he's saying but you know he's taking a
dig at me that's cool whatever we're
gonna get a hold of his characters
um
I would have to go with with what
Sovereign said because come on anytime I
picked up Street Fighter and it was my
go-to right so I'm really anticipating
the street fighter 6 because they made a
bum right remember
um Ken came from a good home to take
money it was that was a different
Dynamic with him and Ryu he came from
money he had a beautiful wife and kids
and never needed to do this so
apparently now Ken is homeless oh lost
the wife and kids lost the money
and he just down and dirty and ready to
get busy but y'all remember
when I think it was uh uh Tekken three
when Paul came back and he had to hear
remember they had the hair physics yeah
they look like Ken yes hey hello yes
hello chapter four I believe he had
second four yeah 3D I think he had to
hear that what they that's when they
were doing hair physics yes this is how
much of a PlayStation fans we are you
know was aggressive and wasn't snitching
um you know the real PlayStation the
dudes was upstairs in the morals and
stuff where they would stand up guys
with a street absolutely rep these dudes
they're looking funny man it's this is
your generation you're like hang out
with them
so it's it's that that Ken was iconic
you know when he did his uh the Flaming
uppercut
he had a swoop to it and you saw a
scrape in the ground and it's just it's
him and Terry Bogart is like my
favorites but I'm gonna actually have to
go with Ken in all regards as The
Ultimate Fighter game yeah
all right so for me outside video game
Captain I would love and I'm surprised
he has it
he probably had a bucket he said smash I
think it's cloud and smash yeah yeah
Cloud I'm running with as far as basic
any other character because I wouldn't
really see him in a serious type joint
though right you know what I'm saying
because the closest we came to was
Tekken had noctis
I believe for one of them that's the one
with the four Dudes with the car right
15 yeah 15. let's not talk about doctors
but in tacky he's lit he's lit so I
would love to have time he's ever been
lit oh somebody got the packs he's okay
yeah so I would add it and then as far
as the regular come on you know I'm
saying you know I got to be the noise
it's got to be the flamingo it's got to
be a rag you know what I'm saying I
gotta get you know loose with it that
that he just is the essence of the run
run show
karate kicking I mean the Taekwondo
based kicking style characters the John
Lewis The Mastermind stuff we would
watch in the crib and be like yo that
dude that's my man now he gonna win the
whole movie
and then we wait to the end to see who
bad survived so I'm from that era Tech
and represents martial arts vocabs to be
the the more accurate of all the games
and harang's taekwondo with flamingo
stands to faint and then shout out to
it's a long time I'll be very
professional but shout out to um Eric
Jacobus who we've had on IOP a long time
ago
V nice kick be nice be nice but we had
all who did the book but we did devotion
caption for the entire hooray yeah
salute to him he did he did uh God of
War right and he did God of War he did
more Kratos no
um
it's it's one choice yeah like I mean
the amount of Victories that I had with
Ken you don't remember when I was
fighting uh Ken and um I'm I'm a total
that's when I made him the Box yes
so listen you know if I want to beat a
box
and we will have these tournaments and
I'm gonna tell you right now if you
order box that means you are the worst
of the worst like you have fell down the
totem pole into the box it was this day
we went to my house it was me Cog and
Ken and we went to my house and he was
like you're throwing that Street Fighter
throw that street fighter and I said
it's gonna be blood in your snow I don't
feel like feces Oh man and I'm gonna
make you the box and I made him the box
he had to walk home that day with us yes
yes and that was my best day so Ken yes
I gotta go with you salute though the
absolute okay so I'll just set it up
back through those songs
teacher no doubt I used to hate Sinister
that man I had so much priority over her
right anyway moving on we gotta move so
let's get into the next topic yeah it is
Lord King we are talking
Sony and we're talking
um exclusivity deals so um news broke
out shout out to The Verge I thought I
want to Sony might be forced to reveal
how much it pays to keep games off Game
Pass and they might be forced to
detailed its exclusivity deals
specifically so um the FTC
um I actually had ruled in favor of
Microsoft on a couple of accounts so
basically the Xbox firm will receive
PlayStation exclusivity contracts in
four years of company records from Saudi
in preparation for the summer summer
trial over Activision Blizzard King so
that yeah the desoti must share all
requested documents with Microsoft
including any exclusivity deals since
January
2019. Microsoft also tried to additional
uh information which was denied but
um they did performance reviews
performance reviews
because you know and what I've been told
by family that that practice and that
thing you don't ask questions you don't
know the answers to yeah and the fact
that Microsoft is getting their lawyers
to ask that question makes me very
curious what the parameters of his of
his bonuses every year are well like I
said it was gonna be interested so
Microsoft did ask for um to the content
license agreements which Sony wanted to
withhold and the judge voted for
Microsoft and said they did not selling
that so they have to give up their
license agreements now the reviews about
yourself what are the performance
reviews and valuation so they said well
yeah you don't need that FM so that was
the dive I brought yourself and then as
far as
um the request to uh deny access to Jim
it's only wanted to deny access to Jim
Ryan's declaration which is interesting
so that Sony did not protest that the
information was relevant but insisted
there was nothing in these documents
that Microsoft didn't already have
access to but the FTC is going to is
denied that request so that that is
interesting so Maxwell's gonna give him
information there and then the limp they
did Microsoft wanted the exclusivity
deals like from all like
it is like the judge like no four years
2019 just gonna give you yeah when Jim's
in charge yeah and then uh two other
custodians so then it gets deeper so
anyway this is a big one this is a big
one um uh King this is your topic
Saudi has to give up this information in
reference to their exclusivity deals
imagine imagine going out and snitching
imagine like yo man they pumping down
the block right over there you see your
man's imagine a cop looking at you and
going but what about you though
yo Microsoft lawyer said you know he
just reminded me of that dude that uh
that we like all on YouTube he does the
skits oh yeah I could just see him doing
something what about you though
Microsoft lawyer said got you now
that's what happens now hey hey you
bring your paperwork
[Laughter]
bring all the stuff you was doing in the
background
is what we doing it completely went left
Jim was like excuse me
I don't have no deals that is going on
why wait a second wait why nobody told
me they can ask me
why you gotta do that hey yo we want all
the stuff that you all are underhanded
dirty stuff you've been doing
all all the blocking and sheisty stuff
that you've been doing all the gag
orders all the amen
hey man you can't put that on Game Pass
man
all that conversations that you were
having uh he's about to come out and
guess what's about to happen once they
see all the stuff that you was doing
they were like oh this dude's dirty
yo did the dirty guy it was the one that
was you implying that they have a check
in history that we're gonna discover
some things about the history well what
we found out is well we don't have to
discover nothing we know what I'm Gonna
Leave This to y'all I got some props
I'll be right back
while he goes to do what he goes to do
oh Lord addict man somebody's gonna have
to reveal this is I thought I thought
this might be interesting to you I know
you don't care about the FTC stuff but I
thought you might be interested because
I remember you being vocal on Twitter as
far as parody As far as exclusivity
deals obviously Final Fantasy VII and
things like that are you interested in
what potentially could come out in these
four years request that uh that Sony has
to provide Xbox to the FTC
um for the most part I I'm I'm okay with
Sony making these kind of deals what I'm
not okay with is them acting like the
victim I I I like that they have to uh
show their laundry uh because it's it's
definitely dirty laundry you know the
skid marks everywhere so I'm just
sitting over here liking what I do like
is just showing that you know
PlayStation they're not the the that's
what I'm looking for the goody two shoes
that everyone will be making them out to
be they they do no wrong you know
there's no corruption it's like look
like we've we've seen over and over
again you know they they have did what
they can to to stop people from giving
them bad reviews they have did what they
can be an anti-consumer and all this is
fine and stuff but uh there's a
difference between acknowledgment and
and ignorance and I feel like they're
people ignore what they do wrong but oh
they give us Bankers they can sit there
uh
okay so what they'll do is you know
instead of acknowledging that yo they're
doing some anti-consumer stuff when it
comes to you know your your information
being stolen but they gave us God of War
when it comes up to you know talking
about whether or not they how they make
practices and you know how they do tied
exclusives whether or not that's good
instead of saying you know I understand
why they do I don't like it but I
understand you know they they give us
last of us it's just like look like what
she said these people
yeah
are you done no no he's ready to talk
about it what is that on your screen
okay that is a stick of recycling Last
of Us yeah what we doing
what are we doing here sir bangers yes
oh yeah ratchet is like definitely
definitely
bangers yes Horizon get to the point
yeah
these are bangers yes these are oh
Spiderman definitely you know we know
what the deal is oh yes we know we know
we know what the deal is these
we all thought these first party bangers
were were sufficient and self-sustaining
we really find out it's all
are you if I'm out that y'all all this
all this
all of this
don't equal it
are you always
threaded him
just do
this what your deal is about
they don't want the information to come
out that this ain't worth yeah
nothing are you implying that Sony
themselves said that they need Call of
Duty to actually fund their first party
Baggers because these dudes don't buy
games
this is where the fear lies in once Call
of Duty get over the Xbox
let's go see that's that's the poison
pill this is what we talking about here
the real prize
it's a multi-plat game that funds all
your fun all your fun all the stuff that
you like to cap about all the stuff that
you like to talk about amen
this is what it is so now you're gonna
put some respect on it so now you know
why they were scrambling and bambling
why you know why oh oh they gotta block
this deal but anything's necessary and
y'all dudes is like I don't even play
Call of Duty anyway
you know what you don't play Call of
Duty but you play these though right
and without this
there's no this that is truth that is
very true and we about to take this away
from you
I know you're messy so now all your
snitching got you to talk about the
facts and the facts of the matter is
you hiding you deceitful you lying Dukes
it's over
and it ain't no concessions Gonna Save
You
so now that we know this is worth more
to them
than all of this that is true all the
money I put here don't matter because
this funds this this away just goes away
I give him this this is messy but this
is your order so I can't wait for it to
happen
I can't wait for you to become this
yo come on Kick not the [__] they gonna
be an app
now come on and we're gonna be able to
download you and played you anywhere
but what I do love is the facts is
coming out the truth see you can't block
the sun with a thumb you know you could
try to hide it you can try to hide the
Sun but it's always Gonna Shine and the
truth shall set you free the truth shall
come out at some point in time so you
can lie as much as you want but now the
paperwork is coming up
when Jim has to sit in front of the
Congress and be like
well um
financially win win Quagmire buddy Call
of Duty helping us out fixing up stuff
you know we got Spider-Man funded
because
because of Call of Duty I can't wait to
take that funding away
is that right
what I could do without steroids
are you a really homegrown are you
applying that's not organic growth it's
not organic because you need to
stimulate
all right
this is the Drake and you guys he got no
bars
that's the secret sauce
all along who knew who knew who was
really the backbone
this is the real Sony
not enough people have never heard
Microsoft say yo without Call of Duty we
won't be able to make God of War I mean
uh Gears of War or Halo or we won't be
able to fund Forza we find out that you
guys can't stand on your own
y'all depending on this drug
why are you making it like they're a
drug addict or something
they're like hey man
please don't take away that Call of Duty
man
it's over
it's over y'all about to go cold turkey
and it's a wrap I've waited for this for
so long why are you waiting for me you
sound like Megatron
go kick yourself I would have waited an
eternity
we've all seen the truth in the
background we've all seen it I don't see
none of these PlayStation dudes capping
no more I see nobody on my timeline I
told you in the end of the days this is
the end of times
it's been prophesied
I don't like this energy and I Am The
Horseman of War
s
who's the statue who's the foreign
[Music]
get out of here now I know why y'all
didn't want feel around
oh okay okay I see what you're doing now
yeah Phil is the one he's the chosen one
y'all just was like nah man he need to
get out of there y'all seeing things
happening
it is divine
oh Odin wished it to be so it's not 30
years old okay okay and he he gave them
the financial backing by the iron he
said what do you need Phil to dispatch
of these
it feels safe
give me an army
and I will decimate them
what all me would you need I would like
to acquire ABK
that was too
high for
field and lay waste to our enemies he
said all I need is Call of Duty
I found the weakness in that armor oh
this is this is the chick this is the
Achilles heel
the supply chain it's like there was
that it's like there was that like an
after party at one like these events and
like it's like Phil and Jim was sitting
there and they drunk and and feeling
Phil's sitting there he's like hey we
tried and the Gym's like yeah you know
what's funny fail he beat you with all
the money we get for Call of Duty it
feels like a word
Phil wasn't even drunk
he
[Music]
did
really really Jim tell me more who did
that for you sir
Phil Dominus Maximus are really
expensive first episode it's like Phil's
sitting there man he's drinking drinking
that water on the Rocks
Jim starts talking he puts the he puts
his phone down recording he's like tell
me more Jim Jim's like God people use
Call of Duty we use that money we fund
everything
Society the next day he's like he's like
we got it it's over this has got to be
kick his most messiest segment in some
time
um I don't even know what to say after
that that was definitely it was some
truth to that so I can't can't go too
crazy on him but um yeah so uh who
didn't talk yeah I forgot what happened
it was me I rounded out or sorry all
right I found it I was just throw it off
but I didn't know what was happening
continue son I apologize
I mean what is there to say like
all the things see this is the thing I
they had to have known this is coming
they're not stupid they've dealt with
stuff like this before they knew this
was coming right they probably didn't
think they they would lose uh the
hearing
yeah yeah but it this is this is why I'm
happy right I'm happy at the fact that I
just feel like in the beginning when you
saw the stuff that Sony was bringing up
I'm like
this is like an argument you would make
to a five-year-old because all you have
to do is Google search and you know that
this stuff is this I'm like I really
hope that these arguments don't hold
water when it really comes down to
deciding if this is which arguments
bothers you which arguments that they
would oh just the stuff about you know
uh uh you know
foreclosure
right we couldn't exist and all this
stuff I'm like you know no no no no no
no no no like it's just none of this
felt
relevant and right and this it just felt
like they were lying I'm like are they
gonna be able to get away with live like
I don't understand this so the fact that
yes when it when when the brass tax hits
and it's time to really start looking
into this stuff they're not playing
around they need to see the real details
before they really come to real
conclusion and for me the fact that all
the stuff that they said till now is
like hey
you're kind of being disingenuous about
about a lot of stuff because you do the
same sorts of things that you were
claiming they're going to do Post
acquisition you do that already
obviously just on a smaller scale yeah
the principle is the same but this case
simple is the same the core of it is the
same the principle is the same and when
I don't want to go back to this stupid
argument about purity and whatever the
right way the right way yeah the right
way because none of it matters because
at the end of the day whether you bought
naughty dog in the beginning when they
were just doing crash or you bought them
now after the successes they've had and
doing last of us and whatever it doesn't
matter you still own them now and that
the fact of the matter is who they are
now is what you got them for so whether
you Aiden and getting there none of that
matters so end of the day
My Hope Is that ft you know FDC looks at
this stuff and it's like look it it's
the way when we think about competition
in this space oh you're talking old and
talk that oh when we talk about
competition in this space so the only
deflection he just did because this is
what you're doing this is the thing
right
competition we talk about whether we
there was there was always there was
this conversation around whether this is
Anti-Trust or whatever that's stupid
that's out the window that's ridiculous
right now the the true argument is are
you creating situations that do not
allow competition to happen right
and in the purest sense of the word you
paying to make sure that another
platform doesn't get something
is eliminating the ability to compete on
an even plane when you eliminate that
from the from from the get that is you
hindering competition not allowing the
not allowing pure and natural and
organic competition be careful some of
these bad boys gonna put stuff in the
chat
you know now now look let's put all the
cards on the table right okay and maybe
maybe this stuff affects affects
negatively maybe it doesn't but I like
the fact that it's gonna be out on the
table you're gonna say look okay how
long how long did we really pay to keep
that ff7 remake off of other platforms
specifically Xbox right because the
Nintendo thing is really just a Nintendo
thing because of it can't run the game
period locally right and if they had if
they had a more robust maybe uh Cloud
offering maybe that would be a thing
that would happen on that end whatever
the case may be the Nintendo the lack of
Nintendo there is not because of hey we
consider them our direct competitor they
don't consider them the direction better
so yeah I just saw let me ask you a
question because you said something and
you gave me a light bulb above
do you think Nintendo decided not to
compete because of the practices of Sony
and decided this to like you know lock
off the ecosystem and concentrate on
that stuff because they knew the stuff
that Sony was doing in the background
and they didn't feel like making a
stronger machine will enable them to
have a lot of these games regardless
because of the third party practices
Sony was doing
I think well when you think about when
it was before Microsoft kind of jumped
into it right and Sony right
you have a whole generation with Sony
Nintendo and and and you know kind of
going at it and no Microsoft in the
mixed Sega still kind of in the mix
part of it Sony's always going to have a
chip on the shoulder I think to a
certain extent when it comes to Nintendo
right I think it's still kind of it sits
in their crawl a little bit that they're
still as successful as they are in their
own lane
um so it could be because but at the
same time you got to remember I don't
know how how Nintendo's changed and
evolved right behind the scenes right
but in the 16-bit era 8-bit era then
that was Nintendo yeah that was Nintendo
be like yeah you wanna yeah you want to
publish on NES yeah um you can only make
five games a year
um and you buying all the cartridges for
us you know it was they they were those
dudes and in the 16-bit era what
happened was they got yanked out from
under them when they were like nah we're
not gonna go thank Sony but no thanks
and it blew up in their face
at the end of the day I just think that
the Nintendo
Nintendo realized and I think a lot of
people realize it is very difficult to
support three consoles on the market
that are identical in terms of close to
identical in terms of power and like if
you had a port of whatever big you know
third-party game for each one of these
consoles that was essentially kind of
the same like we did during the GameCube
generation yeah one is always going to
fall out one of them is it's not going
to support three consoles that are kind
of the same so they realize hey you know
what we can go different direction we
could still stay making money without
having to put out this robust super
machine that competes on a power level
with these guys and we're going to focus
on the things that make us great and
they I can't even be mad at them for
that
um because it's the right thing to do
for them what I do I want to miss you
more power short yeah 100 but not they
whether
they walked away from it because they
know those are practices they used to
engage in and they know the size yeah of
course I I think that that is very true
but now I think they're going to stay in
their land and keep doing what they do
if they if they ever decide to come back
I think it's a mistake you would have to
come back with a machine that's
considerably more powerful than both
whatever PlayStation and they're not
doing that yeah they're not doing that
yeah I agree I think uh Nintendo did the
right thing but kind of formulating
their Lane I felt the switch was the
perfect form factor and then they they
walked this hybrid line of portable and
and console but now as far as the news
you know got no king is in his bag this
is big this is big because there's a
part of me you know that always want to
know how these deals are structured
right and you know y'all don't like the
poll question a lot but um to me you
know Xbox has said prior to this like yo
they block us from putting having third
party have they block their parties from
having their games on Game Pass right
now get it has always been consistent
you do exclusivity deals you have every
right to do how you want to move to make
your ecosystem attractive I I've never
had a problem with exclusives no matter
who does it and if ownership if you buy
a company you buy bungee you buy whoever
right you have the right to do as you
please I've always felt that but the key
here is that if you're going to like
King said
make a deal and I mean you're going to
make a point to say hey this is going to
harm us if if XBox if Microsoft has Call
of Duty right this this is going to harm
us we won't be able to compete like you
know we found out about Call of Duty
does fund to find out that money does
fund a lot of the first person shoes
that solely themselves have come out and
admitted this I mean first person the
first person Banger so to speak that
they have for party Beggars so now we
see because to me there was always like
yo they're going extra hard to preserve
Call of Duty and for me I'm like I know
that Revenue but I don't realize how
substantial that Revenue was and then
obviously it's funding other things you
need this right so the key to me here is
that I agree with King on this I have to
admit and then it says if you're gonna
go out your way to to say this is so
crucial to send you to our business then
the counter is going to be okay well I
need to see how you operate with your
business because
what's fair for the good fair for the
game that kind of thing if you're going
to say that the way we're operating is
farming competition we're going to say
the way you're bid operating has been
harming competition and they're going to
want to see how the structure of those
deals last if is it the situation how
long the exclusivity how long whether it
be used to tell developers game pass the
extended stuff like the Final Fantasy 7
stuff you know where people don't know
the octopath I get I should say
octopathy I could be a square I
shouldn't say Sony has it but we're
gonna find out more things and generally
what happens if y'all remember it
reminds me of the Epic case
with fortnite
and remember at the time Sony ride Sony
was not willing to do cross play and we
were like yo this doesn't why not yeah
like fortnite is the biggest something
that's easy right I didn't understand it
and then the documents came out yeah and
so if shut up and then it I Don't Like
Your Enthusiasm you're doing way too
much I love the exposes yeah but we
found out that they require a fee that's
right we're not giving this for you for
free right people had to pay us and we
found out how sleazy it really was they
they required a fee if they chose to
partake in Cross play that's the way so
he had structured it so we learned
things about it and I think it's
interesting so you know it's a
significant you know win in the court
for Microsoft as far as the last four
years I did think by myself being messy
like give me give me performance reviews
give me your whole entire time
and they wanted deals going on it back
to 2012. I think but they got some key
dudes in there that they tried to slowly
try to exclude and that's Microsoft was
like that they went a minute or
something we want we want all the people
here but the deals the deals back to
2012 was big because they would have
gotten that it would have get showed you
the road map right for how Sony was able
to capitalize on Microsoft's mistakes no
question but it showed you how they
maintained that boot on the neck
throughout that yes PS4 Xbox One
generation yes because at that point
they were so they they like they can
catch a break they could not catch a win
until game okay back compact right Game
Pass right you know what I'm waiting for
the parody Club
well you think that's gonna come out you
think there's something in my
performance wait I can't wait until they
say
with the restrictions yeah you can't
have it on Game Pass and um you can't
have it better than ours I will say this
kid you've been on that I've always felt
that was a little conspiracy but if
something like that come out yeah whoa
that would be crazy yeah you can't I
know they got 12 teraflops and we got a
strong eight
um
they're defending they're defending
competition with caveats and we're
starting to see all the caveats that
that type of competition entailed yes
that's a dirty business bro like you
really it's really a dirty dirty game
now imma be real you know I'm about to
smoke so I don't buy that I don't buy it
but my thing is my thing is
if you doing that you can't get mad what
you call it by the building I've always
said that you if you've been doing
it shiesty business dirty business or
whatever it is yeah can't get bad if
they be like because if if they've been
blocked the whole let's say let's just
say hypothetically comes out and they've
been blocking Xbox for like almost a
whole generation games
PlayStation 4 error where they had the
dominance they had all the momentum
let's say that comes out you know what
I'm saying like bro you can't get mad if
they be like yo we can't do anything we
can't move here and then they go say all
right we're gonna go buy this studio
like this publisher or whatever like I
get it this is it it's gonna get
interesting it's very and that's the
thing though and then in addition to
that they didn't say okay we're gonna
buy the building right this publisher
and continue to compete the same way you
control right say no we're gonna buy all
we're gonna buy all of this and then we
essentially quote unquote gonna give it
to the fans for free you know whatever
yeah and that to me there isn't it's
kind of weird that now they're focusing
on the cloud stuff a little bit more and
that makes sense in the long term but
they still haven't focused on like this
idea that game pass itself could could
foreclose on their way of selling games
right
and that's weird to me because it's like
you know if this becomes a thing
remember I think Microsoft is one of the
few companies that could just bankroll
something that that let's say this
losing money right we're not making
money right they the only ones that
could bankroll this to Kingdom Come and
not care right
it just it feels like
it feels like an L is coming for Sony
right
it really does it really does I I can
see that obviously the EU resistance
we're gonna see all that
um the UK resistance
yeah we'll talk to you next yeah the CMA
stuff um but at the end of the day like
it I do look Phil Phil ain't Petty like
that so if they're able to get away with
this passing without having to give up
those concessions they're gonna get the
deal they're gonna get the deal what's
up my man ain't Petty like that you're
not that petty yeah
he's not gonna not give them yeah no
okay this is what I see this is what I
first of all
my man will slice you with a smile
I know that okay like I know this
because we got we got a major league uh
MLB the Show
yes that was that that was cold blooded
he was quick to pop off a Twitter with
that one yeah that was cold blooded I've
ever seen from a CEO but
the fact that he knew
this one game
could stop your whole blow flow like
your whole yo yo yo yo know your Vibe yo
yo how you rock
it's like a liver punch like a liver
punch are you say that Phil greatest
thing is that he found the weak spot he
found yo you know in the video in in in
karate movies yeah and the five deadly
venoms oh it was total right and toe was
invulnerable snake
trying it and we knew that battle snake
was gonna get beat
last second
toe goes ah this scorpion he's here
what's going on where is he and he's
looking in the crowd because he had
snake right where he wanted him but it
was all a setup after five daily Venom's
King he went in there with his arrogance
he went in there with the undefeated
streak
and at the end of the day he got locked
into Iron Maiden
and told got killed
are you implying this slowly is told
from five deadly medals
and Phil Domin ance Maximus are really
expensive
is the only CEO in Xbox history
that has found your weakness wow this is
favorite you better be this deal better
go through because if it don't [__]
come for you listen listen I'm so
confident I told you before I was going
through oh he's the Lord Odin said the
closer in it ain't no deal that he went
to go get they didn't get got oh that's
because we still got Discord on Xbox
you see a hook a crook
it's going down
I really still better not get blocking
you popping off it's gonna go down and
funding
the funding
I can't with these props I don't like
you with props for all it is this is
crazy because this is a wild stack the
phone with this stack right this stack
was a quick this is a crazy stack as
[__] I got more I could have did more I
didn't it don't matter
matter see best selling franchise on a
PlayStation 4.
they put it on the back of the box
the best seller so all your franchises
here is not the best selling
he left bread crumbs all around the
world for you to see
if Phil just deciphoned it brought it
down
crack the code
and they're about to crack your back
like Bob back
you just pissed off the fair boys I
can't wait for this to happen Xbox dude
stand up is about to go down is about to
be finished
okay that's what it says it's curtains
ladies
yo you got Swift bad with me Chicago
this fake Nutri tip I never claim to be
neutral sir and we all have preferences
we all have preferences I mean that's
just what it is I'm just my [__] being
fair and at the end of the day [__] is
what it is we gonna see the truth gonna
come out regardless the saga continues
but I don't really have much much too
much to add to it it's just yeah this is
Xbox the trillion dollar company
Microsoft does not need any of us
defending them you know but but the fact
of the matter is that in this case
when it comes down to what they're
trying to do I've said this a million
times
when you have a subscription service
your goal is to own the vast majority of
the stuff that is in that service tracks
they were always going to continue to
try to grow this opportunity presented
itself hey hey
guys you know okay I don't think they
ever intend I think when when this was
even a Phil was like really we could do
that because it was it's something you
wouldn't even think about with
especially with Activision the Call of
Duty machine you're like nah this ain't
going nowhere and then little by little
chinks in the armor show themselves all
the stuff with the with the with the
studios and the Bad actors and all the
bad stuff happening over there so oh all
of a sudden in this environment mind you
if all that stuff would come out 10 15
years ago in the gaming space nobody
would care but it's nobody would care
that Bobby Cole dick is accused of all
that nobody in this environment it was a
perfect storm of things that happened
that allowed Phil to be able to make
that call they were like yeah actually
let's have that discussion hold up so
again they don't need us to defend them
it is just one of those things where
when when the arguments that are made
are disingenuous because you engage in
those same things there's going to be
pushback and I'm just I'm just again I'm
happy that
I was proven wrong that the due process
that has to happen during this this this
this this process is thorough and isn't
some just fly by night like yeah you
know
I checked Google and Google said it was
it was nah it was it wasn't a goal like
you know what I mean like right so I'm
just glad that the details the the eyes
are being dotted the t's are being
crossed and due process is happening we
shall see but that's all I got we
probably could transition right into the
next one which is yeah hold on a second
let me let me get you Super Chat we got
a lot yeah we got a couple yeah not a
lot it went out and we went up because
we we passed the um 50 Mark really good
thank you guys everybody this is
contributing to uh the road to PAX East
it's gonna be something fun so thank you
yeah right now it's looking like kings
going to be playing a retro game
oh I don't trust your pulse and we
talked about that yeah 419 votes you
don't trust me so you don't you don't
trust the community you don't trust them
around you don't think about it this way
guys y'all want to see me play a retro
game but see y'all was thinking it was
going to be secular right that's that's
that's what the whole of vote are you
putting words in their mouth no it's
supposed to be a retro game so we're
talking about turbo Graphics we're
talking about Sega Genesis
it says what Lords is playing retro
games it doesn't say Sakura yeah well so
see you guys so y'all was voting for a
second though take your vote back and
vote on the attic
let me start reading this because the
purpose of [__] taking a break was to be
able to go through these so hold on a
second I don't remember it was a street
fighter one
um
damn it
okay Lord Metroid remember for 17 months
Lord Silver Street Fighter 6 with the
community hopefully um game great show
as usual May the 12th baby May the 12th
salute to the Lords and chat s yes it's
gonna happen that would do it for sure
Robert kellett two dollar Super Chat
thriving Ryan snitching on his own joint
[Laughter]
so there we go self snitching yeah
Tom from Toonami to another Super chat
you can you can just see Jim sitting at
the table with the FTC like Norman
Osborne from Spider-Man with the board
oh I remember that no you can't do this
to me I started this complaint do you
know how much I sacrifice wow
yeah that's the shout out to William
Defoe one of the phone
get him out the building and take his
peacock away
thank you you get the little drip of
spit coming down
yeah messy and we got Edwin Garcia five
dollar Super Chat what do you guys think
of the rumor that Sony might be buying
take two yo I saw that and then I kind
of did nobody followed up on it so I was
like I don't know where this came from
it comes from the fear of losing yo
y'all trying to cushion the blue I don't
worry they're gonna lose the ABK thing
but they are going to get the the Grand
Theft Auto
and I heard 50 Cent is gonna be playing
one of the captions
y'all can sit there and try to cushion
this blow all you like this is what
matters
they don't they say nothing about Grand
Theft Auto nobody cares about you
they care about this messy bro I mean
GTA 5 is a beast but it didn't go for
six days does it does it compare it does
it compare to Call of Duty year in year
out like I don't know they get the money
like that that ain't been on their list
like that so we're gonna take one at a
time first I heard that in one place and
then nobody followed up on it so I don't
know where it came from uh it was
somebody else trying to make news all
right then we got Lawrence Davenport
remember for two months five dollar
Super Chat dirt is too dark and too
strong what I don't know what we're
doing okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah it could be you'll see tempura
five dollar Super Chat these PlayStation
Fanboys need to stop by two maybe three
copies from now on to fund the bangers
it won't matter
then we got Matthew Ash two dollars for
the chat sending that Cod stimulus money
yo
potatoes
they need a bailout
Robert Kelley fifty dollars
in the Lord's work it's funny what's
funny is I'm not allowed to laugh now
like when kids in his bag even though I
could be objective like you're not
supposed to be laughing
hey bro like even if it's against me
he's one of the funniest people
it was
it
it's gonna go down
you you will be unbearable yes yes I
already know it's going to be a six hour
stream yeah the whole Community going
water park because they go like King's
Pizza we want to be here for this then
if I have a specter to your greatness
and your foolishness I just sit here I
think it's funny like even when
something goes against this last thing I
want to get off to the to the chat even
with something that King does goes
against something I like it is still
hilarious it's the whole point like
y'all gotta learn even if you're on the
other side of something you gotta learn
to laugh at something that's funny
because you got to see the humor in it
don't take it so personal Infinity
Gauntlet and I'm gonna Snap My Fingers
about stuff I love like this band with
Roy Jones law sent me some wild
disrespectful that's just how he is like
like King will do that he will push that
button and y'all gotta learn chat like
that's just him trolling in his bag you
gotta let him hook that when he has his
moments you allow him to cook
I just think it's so funny when they say
well Jim you know you got to bring
documents too what
[Laughter]
don't come here to watch my hero get
destroyed what was messed up was Thomas
said you got any excuses tonight bro
I knew I was in for a long night and I
smashed my hero get demolished something
you don't ever want to hit facts because
he's just predicting the win yeah and
that's what you doing
down oh so it hurts but I Gotta Laugh I
was mad with cake for a while but I had
the left it's funny is what king just
said we got splendiferous one year
remember for one year two last Super
Chat Jim Wright oh so we gotta tell the
truth
yo that's funny all right that was funny
that was good that was good I like that
I like that one y'all leave y'all back
today then we got cold weed five dollars
to pretend I said before Phil is the
founding Titan and the Xbox rumbling has
begun as king said before there's no ps6
they won a competition like they they
said you're literally why don't
Microsoft you know act like you know the
trillion dollar company they are
now you regret you then we got Raiden
blade but for two years Tupac Super Chat
play Bad Dudes versus dragon ninja if
possible incredible is that bad dudes
versus Double Dragon yeah that was a
classic bad yeah that was yeah that was
a classic yeah because bad news by
itself ain't great but yeah yeah it
didn't hold up too well yeah then we got
Raiden blading once again remember for
two years five pounds Super Chat I'm a
Ryu guy and we'll destroy any can player
oh okay so I want my back dosan back in
Tekken no back no Tekken eight back dude
dope son salute citizen would love that
yeah he was a beast it would be nice to
buy a kickback because otherwise hurray
will take your moveset though he talking
all that just see you on the street
fighter when you show up don't talk
about it be about it
we have puckish Rogue one hundred five
dollars per chat what if Nintendo
decided to publish on Xbox let's put uh
the crest in the chat for puckish rogue
that is their first Super Chat oh
absolutely thank you much love
what if Nintendo decided to publish on
Xbox uh that might again that that was
one of those things when they we didn't
know what the switch was or whether it
was coming and after the Fiasco of the
uh
the Wii U but nah they're good now
unless they just drop the ball again we
don't know I don't know but I don't know
what the deal entails and yeah if we get
something crazy you
yeah it would be so imagine that a
freaking Nintendo game on Xbox
yeah relax I got a shot or relax I
understand y'all popping bottles now
relax
Wario rabbits oh here we go
m p five dollar Super Chat that's off to
you for what you're trying to bring in
the community and a big shout out to
King for helping me get my bellary issue
solved okay absolutely
I cannot wait to everybody get these
pillows and I can't wait to see you guys
that packs yes and remember uh it's it's
it's a special thing with those pack
shirts oh yeah oh yeah get those pack
shirts you already know I've got Evan
Pete you know that we read that one
clutchman 0-1 5 super chat Sony secrecy
on the third party business practices
sounds like a Jason schreier
investigation in the making chat let's
put that in his ear yeah I'm pretty sure
that he has a lot of information that he
doesn't want to hurt them with because I
think he actually likes Sony
um he's going to be a point where it's
going to be more profitable let that
information go
then we got briscoe's Son Two Dollars
Super Chat Phil Caster Troy Jim for the
bomb location now shout out today the
Face-Off face off
yes yes
then we have temper once again five
dollars for chat what's also so funny to
me is people saying they can't compete
with Cod but they have bangers though
they make the best games yes they can
Socom Socom is fire though man you got
to bring back some comments Socom got to
come back at something kind of different
but but they have stuff to work with
this idea that we can't possibly begin
to comprehend what God is it's like we
can comprehend exactly what God is is
the best-selling franchise on the pieces
we know exactly what this is on the box
it's on the box so put your so calm away
and just wrap it up rap it up
you ain't getting no better than this
two dollars give Jim a one ply roll to
wipe his mouth
respectful sir
we got
yeah you guys just gonna have a lot of
residue
leftover tissue pump
and we got mad men X member for four
months Lord goes out to you sir I won't
be able to attend packs East this year
to meet the Lords I want to say thank
you for the love hilarious banter and
amazing takes on the gaming industry you
guys make my fight with PTSD easy
appreciate that man that's what it's
about bro that's what it's about right
anything we can do to put a smile on the
face jokes about having fun bro like
exactly that's why the toilet humor is
important I don't want cotton but if I
can save one cotton button
shout out to do wipes gives we got to
give kick this Foster ship
let's put the crust in the chat welcome
to Lord silver why low King Cloud Willow
I think it's whilo King Cloud King Cloud
no doubt shout out to you sir appreciate
you brother Saloon
then we have Corey Tidwell five dollars
for the chat at FTC you have to block
this deal so King can stop hurting our
feelings PlayStation Nation down bad wow
they're gonna show this video and I say
see he even knows
it's over messy messy Gerald Mack two
dollar Super Chat The Game Pass
Avalanche has begun bro you don't even
know
it's a big year it's a big year
then we got Hollywood rules five dollar
Super Chat just got back in from seeing
Creed with my son have a great Sunday
fellas Sony dug their own grave Phil and
Sacha handed them the shovel get em King
this is true once once you built your
your business model on one franchise
sustaining everything and you don't own
said franchise
that's your fault
the other two seem to be getting along
pretty fine
you know without fighting for certain
things you know Microsoft gave up the
well they didn't pursue the marketing
deals with Call of Duty because they
wanted to focus on the other stuff
Nintendo doesn't even have it over there
so if you built your whole business
model off of this
all they had to do is just come kick the
leg out and you're building gonna fall
yeah but I'll be in In fairness I did
think that it was smart of them to get
the marketing rights because I feel oh
for them yeah was critical for 360. to
me 360 was known as the Call of Duty
machine and I was surprised Microsoft
didn't follow up to renew the contract
in the Next Generation
okay and no I'm I'm saying your points
is valid right
Microsoft did the same thing Sony did
with that Call of Duty stuff
they didn't invest in their own stuff
right so that that left them kind of
messed up Sony said what we can do the
Call of Duty stuff we have this stuff
here we can just use Call of Duty to
fund all this other stuff yeah Microsoft
had to take a step back to get their
stuff together to get their house in
order in order to pursue that so it was
just a tale of two stories if they can
if they continued with the Call of Duty
stuff they would still be the same
Microsoft with the Call of Duty
marketing
um maybe PlayStation will be a little
weaker but they won't be we can get them
out the door weaker interesting now that
you can get them out the door now the
PlayStation 6 is really in jeopardy
watch that
[Laughter]
I like it
happens to Wolverine if this thing
happens oh but you feel yourself too
much sir continue to continue yourself
he's out of pocket I guess I think we're
caught up did we get any more of them oh
we got the doctor yeah 63 five dollars a
time I like how I can go to a full
church service get food come home and
the podcast is still going strong I
believe I'm default this one because I
addict Was Fear I can tell you it's
Fierce for me about VR review of
PlayStation he's like I'm just talking
too long I appreciate that [__] since I
kept getting interrupted last week
yeah those two would be a messy with you
so I had to get paid them back exactly
but um anyway so look let's get into it
so if this is your topic um if you want
me to set up the EU part or you good or
yeah go ahead set it up it's kind of
just jumping off of what uh yeah so
shout out to is it routers Reuters
Reuters Reuters Reuters exclusive micro
set Microsoft set to win EU nod on
Activision with licensing off resources
say so this is out of Brussels Microsoft
Corp will unexpected to secure the EU
Anti-Trust approval for a 69 billion
Activision of um Activision with its
offer of Licensing deals to rivals three
people familiar with the matter set
helping it to clear a major hurdle so
they go on to talk about
um you know Tony tencent they start to
talk about the European commission which
is scheduled to decide on the deal by
April 25th is not expected to demand
that Microsoft sell assets to what its
approval the people's sense of no
diversity and in addition to the
licensing deals for Rivals Microsoft may
also have to offer other behavioral
remedies to allay concerns of other
parties than Sony one of the people who
said such remedies typically refer I
like this line to the Future conduct of
the merged company like I like that just
to me did those like yo we gonna have
someone in the building
I think that's the funniest line but
anyways yeah that's pretty much the the
initial set up I don't know where you
want to go with it or saw but yeah
what's your what's your thoughts I mean
it's pretty kind of dry I I tell you
guys I'm tired to talk about this I am
but this at least we're getting some
more definitive movement right so I
think this is important again obviously
there's two two major hurdles still with
the UK and the CMA and the FTC but for
the European commission and all it took
all it took in the European commission
was really looking strongly at the cloud
stuff all it took was for them to say
Hey you know all those Azure servers
that we have they can run Call of Duty
anyway which way
that's fine we'll have them there
for us now yeah arguably more powerful
than what we have yeah not not as
prolific in terms of where where it's
situated but more powerful if there's an
uh there's an alternative option to be
had well you know this is this is higher
Fidelity they run 40 80s 40 90s in their
servers
we have every reason to not want to give
them this because the product will show
better on theirs
than our platform here you go 10 years
there you go it doesn't matter to us
Nintendo whatever Nintendo's cooking up
whether it be Cloud whether it be the
mobile versions of cod whether it be
whatever the case may be we're going to
find a way that's signed and done for
him that that's a done deal
so
to me this goes back to what I talked
about last week where it's like
whether Microsoft wanted to or not they
kind of showed their hand long term
already because it had to right in order
for these concessions to go through this
was the big sticking point if they had
said no to this the European Union might
have had a bigger problem and we'd be
sitting going through more of this red
tape and different types of concessions
would have to be had
which would be a little bit weird like
what you said about the the the
behaviors
you've already given them 10 years of
guaranteed Behavior watch you son we
gotta watch you because you got people
like King in the building putting on the
ability to talk about Order 66 off watch
them dudes so I don't know what that
means really because again you're
guaranteeing 10 years of a guaranteed
Behavior guaranteed parity you're
guaranteed content parity everything
everything everything in terms of how
that game runs looks plays everything
you can access is going to be the same
across the board
because it behooves them for that to be
the case they are this if they if they
win this and they're able to finally
complete this purchase they will be the
stewards of Call of Duty it doesn't
behoove them for Call of Duty to work
poorly anywhere right that is the truth
that is absolutely just become the lead
platform but exactly right
so this is the thing when they talk
about these behaviors
and they get into the Nitty Gritty
details of that is there
someone in the room smart enough to
argue The Game Pass argument right okay
there's feature parody there's content
parody there is not point of sale parody
what happens there and that to me is is
going to be as if yeah obviously they're
very smart people in the room I'm
assuming somebody has this argument what
does it mean for that because guaranteed
is going into your service
automatically like King said that makes
you the lead platform uh automatically
if I'm if I'm a consumer and I'm like
where am I going to go with this where's
the one that's quote unquote free I'm
gonna go to Game Pass
and now the interesting part didn't did
they not and I don't know if this was
conjecture or this was true that it was
said hey we're even offering it to
PlayStation and PS plus is that is that
good job was that I didn't see
PlayStation Plus percent so I just heard
PlayStation that we are not rip it away
and treated in the same way like it
would be if Minecraft they would use
Minecraft as the example the example of
a legacy content so whether that's true
or not the fact of the matter is this is
Microsoft's game play long term if I I
know you guys talked during the week uh
in Duke you guys talked about this this
idea of Microsoft selling off Xbox right
if this doesn't go through right and I
will say this right anything can happen
the thing about it is and this is very
true right
Xbox Phil has a seat at the table now
right so the considerations for Xbox are
greater than they ever have been right
they're going to the the leeway there
right and the opportunity for the game
plan to play out is going to be given
now if at the end of 10 years or
whatever
the profits aren't there the
subscription numbers aren't there I
could see a situation was like okay well
now this isn't well I don't know about
closing Xbox I can see a situation where
they're like well we can't do Game Pass
anymore I can see it because the
business is a business right right it
would look ugly and foul and horrible
for the consumer not a good look
whatsoever agreed but business is
business
now could that in long term lead to them
being like okay we don't want to be in
the video game business anymore yes it
could in the long term is this
is this purchase
so imperative that that that hangs in
the balance if it doesn't happen no I
don't think so they're just going to go
buy more stuff in smaller bits and
pieces so that it doesn't look as
shiesty or you know to whatever you know
to whatever governing bodies are looking
um so that's it I mean to me this is a
big hurdle right if this goes through
the only concession it needed to me was
to guarantee that they weren't going to
lock it off onto their own cloud service
and now this think about
the crazy thing about it is if you think
about how Paradigm shifting this is if
this goes through
the landscape of gaming changes that is
for sure epic this is one of those
pivotal moments in gaming industry for
sure it really is yes regardless of what
happened to this pivotal right because
again the smoke that has happened if it
doesn't go down will be interesting too
if there is that pettiness that used to
talk about Cog right if that pettiness
does exist then alliances will be made
right and battle lines will be drawn
right because if it doesn't go through
Bobby kotik most likely we'll stay in
Activision Blizzard and then exactly we
know the Call of Duty licensing ends in
2024.24 we got to see all that
relationship golden parachutes and
situations so yeah yeah so the
investiture of the business was never it
was never going to happen because that
at that point the deal is dead that is
not going to happen that would not
happen and
if if the CMA makes that a sticking
point I I am interested to see
how that's gotten around if they make
that a sticking point they know it has
to be broken up
um
but we'll see we'll see again I I hate
talking about this but this is there's
finally some forward movement and I'm
happy to see it we're getting dates
obviously August is the is the sort of
date for for the trial of the FTC trial
and we'll see how that goes but
you know it is one of those things where
it feels like the hurdles are being
jumped over
you know eyes are being dotted T's are
being crossed and at the end of the day
what's gonna happen is I feel like
they're just not going to be able to
find enough reasons why it it should not
go through rather than finding reasons
why it's positive or whatever because
none of this stuff ever pans out that
way it's just enough you can't you can't
justify not let it go through by what
you found right and whatever which way
it happens I think it's gonna happen
this is very interesting to me and uh
you know shout out to everborn because
ever born has been eating sleeping
breathing this stuff since it happened
he has he has he is so invested he's
invested yes I want to hear I want to
hear that Soliloquy because you know
the Queen's a legendary I want to hear
this way
yeah let's uh get to it um addict you
know I know you've been following this
thing you know like a fine-tuned comb
you've been all over he's all about this
you are so invested with the ABK deal I
just couldn't wait to hear your expert
opinion on this so um where you at with
the latest findings at the potential uh
EU potentially by Reuters writers always
butcher
um saying that it's a potential that it
could go through in the EU
at this point I'm at I'm at the point
where I'm like Phil
for all the people that's doing it uh
you know the commission or whatever that
organization is called the CDN
commission
gym right I'm like just catch me outside
catch me outside of my dad let's be
outside with that verdict but until then
I I I I'ma stay over here and play this
wulong and when it's done on the CDC
it's a disease in the qss
when they all came up with their
decision you know I will talk about it
on that podcast but on this one Yo cool
cool the scene day
I don't like you being disrespected the
CDC
yeah he'll purposely butchering
that was messy as hell
foreigners you know they they think that
someone said the CDC definitely about to
decline this dude I can hold the
ceilings here real effect that's harming
competition
we doing some harming we doing some harm
in CDC but uh yeah Kings I see you
popping bottles and stuff
um but yeah rumors you know rumors but
alleged that the old may go through with
the EU with the APK so what do you feel
right now I feel good
he knew that I would
yo
yo oh good
here we go you dudes are in danger
like yo it's like playing a game with
fortnite you know people can take
bounties out on you right and then it is
say like let's say we're in a group of
four
and it'll say Protect Sovereign
level like when they when they're not
close you don't care but when that bar
is all red that mean they're around you
your bar is red boy
they
have a whole Convoy circling you right
now
and they just waiting for the EU to say
good fire
what are we doing we're doing War now
[Laughter]
they rated on my city what we doing yo I
cannot wait for that day I'm gonna jump
on Twitter hard like pause it's going to
be a live stream you're gonna you
popping bottles for real
you know what it is
it's all about Sega oh my god oh here we
go this is all about Sega here we go and
um the information is coming out you
know
you just really gonna find out the truth
what really happened to Sega like you
know the cold cases it was a cold case
it was a Cold Case
America's Most Wanted you know so many
things is going on and then
we got a confidential informant
that starts snitching on himself
[Laughter]
and you know you know the D.A
now you know you don't mess up oh that's
a lie
now you know you know you're done messed
up
I was there at nine o'clock and uh uh
yeah so you was there seven yeah I was
there at seven o'clock yeah so so I said
I said like I said uh no uh yeah but
that's a classic seed That's a classic
seed I know what y'all doing what y'all
doing
yo this deal they said see now Rutgers
everybody before like weeks before it
charged a 40 chance that it doesn't get
past Tony seems to be in Prime polls he
said Rutgers after Rutgers University
you know
they're they're in Prime pole positions
to make sure that they blocked this deal
Sony has definitely gave information
that seems to be detrimental to Xbox and
when it comes to this deal and FTC it
seems to be favoring Sony at this point
because all the Talking Points have
definitely been in Sony's favor so wait
a second wait hello
oh
um no information they found out Jim
snitching yeah wait a second self
snitching uh Sony has to produce paper
paperwork on all the stuff that they've
been doing all right so right now
um we have got new information Sony is
in big trouble
uh this this deal looks like it's about
to be passed by the EU ABK deal is about
to go through um I think they lost a
foothold there yeah Jim's dirt is coming
up and um
sad to say PlayStation 6 seems to be a
rap
okay okay they can't fund this stuff no
more so it's over
[Music]
we don't know what happens to Future
franchises once they lose a deal no
you said something about uh
the Call of Duty be inside PlayStation
Plus and and they Services yeah great
give it to them give it to him yeah hell
yeah hell yeah
but they still got to pay them for
potential sale loss oh yeah right that's
the money up front that's right give me
the bag now
you ain't had a bag to begin with
that's why I was never in your service
she once it become a hormone franchise
we don't care
we don't care we're not losing anything
we gaining baby so we won it over there
please put in your service please we
want everybody to have a chance to play
Call of Duty
we just don't want you to benefit like
he was doing before
so the win at the EU it will it will be
it would be splendiferous
that name never felt more poetic than
right now and I know why he can't
because it was a such it was such a
great moment that he came up with that
name different this is me but it's my
name it's been different risk it's a
it's a great moment and it's going to be
a great moment it's gonna happen hey yo
guys I want you Xbox dudes to get ready
get your controllers ready get in pole
position because it's about to come down
anytime now I think
once the star feels you know uh show
comes up
and once the Starfield you know show
happens and they announce Starfield
coming out
it's just gonna be an avalanche a good
news
it's just good because you'll be like oh
we got stuff real game pass is crazy and
there's your red phone again that's the
cracks you know we we got Minecraft
again it came out this is crazy it's
it's just gonna be
dude for shadowing now yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah then they're gonna be like
yeah Call of Duty get your ass is crazy
end of the year oh hell blade too you're
crazy
E3 is it's nuts it's gonna get to a
point where the blows is gonna be coming
too fast and Too Furious and they can't
get up off the floor but it all starts
with the you EU and EU we're looking at
you all eyes are on you right now kid
it's like a Tupac album all eyes on me
and we watching to see what you gonna do
and we we're we're anticipating the the
the the real answer because once y'all
started asking for real paperwork and
once and once y'all decided to sit down
and and really look at what Jim was
doing
love right now I'm doing too much
it's on right now you be doing too much
yeah I know you are I know you are uh
yeah look not much to add to the
commentary here
um
look if if it does we've been here
before they kind of announced when they
thought that they was going to get
blocked before and then it kind of
happened and then now they seemed like
this
that it just feels like if this is the
case that Microsoft sold I mean excuse
me that what soft said is accurate that
going there explaining how the console
business Works in a sense and then the
nasic market of cloud because that was
the thing I was concerned for them
because I was like Azure was strong and
I think if it does go through then I
think that Nvidia might have been the
blow to put it over the edge that
they'll put it over there yeah to give
to give your competitor who has a
dominant product in this space a very
high quality low latency running on 40
90s you know what I'm saying and
streaming kind of situ oh you know it's
on when added got the pillow so the
Villari pillow we almost done at it we
almost done
so then the south of Villari go to uh
Valaria click that to chat use code Lord
15 get that 50 so that YouTube could be
comfortable like by man Lord attic right
now look at that below
right now and we out in the EU and the
UK in those regions that this deal is
about to go
hit the link at the top but anyway I'll
finish up um yeah I think that would be
the the the key factor you know besides
the Nintendo to show them that hey that
they're willing to put Call of Duty on
these other platforms and the cloud
market so yeah we just got to see how it
goes down hopefully soccer continues
April 25th and we will see so that's
what I got super chats and then final
topic yes okay we got to do
argue to me remember for one year ten
dollar super chats little brothers
looking forward to seeing you here in
Boston in a few weeks can't wait for ABK
to complete so we start the whole cycle
again with the next acquisition
oh geek man looking forward to seeing
you brother yes
I don't think it's gonna if they buy
another company
as long as it's not like Ubisoft or EA I
don't think we'll ever have to go
through this everything yo what if it's
take two oh Lord then I'm done I'm
retiring from the podcast but I'm not
talking about about them having this
what if that is
a year and a half not even a little bit
not even a lot if they bought if they
bought 2K I'm a it's a rap I'm out like
because then we're gonna have to talk
about that for another year and then
not to talk about it I got to hear
everybody else
2K yeah no I think they'll be paying
around that too much okay I think it's
like 30 billion years 30 billion not 70.
yeah yeah you act like they're gonna pay
30 billion no they would pay more than
what the company's worth oh sure yeah
for sure
that's what a hostile takeover is
if we give you a good 40 shut up sit
down you know everybody's Pockets get
wet we good all right now bring come on
in but one of the plot twist because we
already know Sony ain't got no 30
billion so that's why that's why that
news went flat so that's why those dudes
is out there throwing out names and
somebody told them hey bro bro bro ain't
got no 30 billion
I saw that and no big Outlet picked it
up okay here's the thing here's the
thing we know they broke so Sony
couldn't Sony could get that money
because they they have the the name
recognition
here's the here's the here's the thing
though like they wouldn't be able the
Microsoft when you're talking about just
spending cash versus spending debt and
assets and stuff it's a lot easier to
convince your your shareholders that
that's a good ideal Sony would have a
hard time convincing them that and I
think you know they could they could get
that money together they could but is
Sony willing to risk their company to to
make that bet and I don't think that's I
don't think that's it I don't know
franchise they put up they could try to
make Superstars out of The Last of Us
they could try to hey man we hot on HBO
Max we can yo this right now yo this
right here
they sound like a like a pyramid scheme
in this right now man they like prime
America
yo I'm probably American gotta get
s it up if you invest right now man I'm
gonna tell you you could be at ground
level of what we're about to achieve you
know yeah Microsoft did the ABK bill
that don't affect us even though we know
that Call of Duty you know helped us do
everything but what we gonna do right
now yeah that's a good point someone
said Sony can't fund all these games
plus take two games yeah they because
because there's more than just buying a
company it's way more than that yeah
obviously we know they ain't got 30
billion I don't care what it says I
don't care about what they can do after
we gotta worry about acquiring and they
don't got acquiring money they can
acquire something small they can buy you
know hey let's get what's how smart they
can buy it they can buy developers they
can't buy Publishers yeah it's it's I
mean they can probably get some like
Square Enix you know but even buying a
company like that they're still worth in
the billions like it's still gonna be
something I had to convince
shareholders that's a good idea and I
don't I don't know man because you know
what we're talking probably what what
they make in a financial year you know
what I'm saying like that's a huge risk
they're not gonna do that
um Eddie you said sticking by a square
my thought with Sony and it has always
been the same with them
they will not buy the cow if they get in
the milk for free yeah I mean but that
depends on how much score is even worth
and how much they make and I think
Square pigeon hold their self to not
give them leverage by being so capitulin
to whatever Sony asks right so if you if
you have a lap dog anyway
it makes no sense to give him extra
porridge when he's been living off the
Porres you've been given right right so
I'm not gonna spend any money to buy you
to take on your headaches when I just
see you every once in a while and have
fun and that's about it I'm not I'm not
trying to invest in your life and right
now I think square is at its lowest to
be honest with you you know with the
foreclosure and all those other games
that weren't really good yeah
yeah so you know they're in the midst of
doing things over there it'll be crazy
it's a new leadership
isn't about locking their titles like
that and you start seeing these games
come to Xbox because he feels that's the
best way to get more money or it's the
new leadership it's more open to sell
into my Christmas yo it's just the thing
about it is like when you really think
about this closing off of stuff back in
the day it made more sense because these
consoles are very different they were
built very differently these consoles
are not built that differently they have
their little their differences here and
there whatever but overall there's no
you should not be taking a year I I
think I mean again I don't know anything
about this but it just makes sense that
these consoles that are built kind of
like PCS it would be weird to me that
you take a super long like you can you
can't make the reasonable argument that
why not put it out on all these
platforms because the conversion time is
what six months maybe if that like it's
just very weird to me that that that
that that anything but that would be the
cause right and so it again I don't know
what these issues are I've talked about
this before it just feels like
how often do you really see a Japanese
company go under like under under like
it doesn't happen because the truth of
the matter is Japanese companies protect
one another yeah
Sony and Square Enix have bought into
each other's companies right in times
just to survive so it is one of those
things where there I do think there is
this this big
I want to call it collusion or anything
but they protect one another and I do
think to an extent to an extent we watch
um any sea go under
you know we watched a couple of
companies Sega right well Sega as a
console manufacturer so let me shut down
um
um Japan Studio
but remember remember King that happened
at a time when Japan was so dominant if
you think about it when you start
thinking about the threat of the western
world and kind of taking who would have
thought the Western world would kind of
take over video games right uh never
thought that right so now I think the
thinking is different it's different
like what it's considerably smaller the
gaming space over there than it was ever
was when we were growing up so think
about it in that respect I do think they
kind of protect one another right
because it's like okay that's much
smaller I like for me I want I would
have loved to have been in the room and
Tango sold to Bethesda because it must
have been some conversations there like
the money's great but but this is kind
of unprecedented yeah uh so I you know
I to me it's partially that and people
don't want to admit that but I think
it's partially that and the whole
argument about it not selling on a
platform and not being worth it I don't
think the investment is so crazy that it
would not be worth it for you to sell
this plan you're not going to sell um at
least a million copies of ff7 remake on
the Xbox really all right but if the bag
is to keep it exclusive it's a nice bag
that to help offset that sale to keep it
ordered
then it's gonna come out though see oh
it's about the paperwork yeah they kept
it was going to operate in the shadows
like they've been doing for years and
nobody was going to call them out nobody
would ever call them out had they not
called their cell phone
we would have never known a lot of a lot
of this stuff that's coming out right
now the dirty laundry is about to really
be seen because we know with the
internet people get pictures of
documents that's across the room I don't
know how they did it like you know
people with telescopes telescopic lenses
uh get these paperworks and get these
pitches
um we're gonna find out what's the real
deal what happened to Final Fantasy
coming to Xbox and what's going on with
square because I think the changing at
the top is maybe the shareholders is
like oh wait a second bro if this games
was on other uh platforms we could
offset a ton of money here we could have
made money it's possible so when they
were at a point where they were making
these games it's not
it's not conducive to good growth by
keeping it segmented to a console and
making that one console
the face of your your franchises
when there's other ways for you to make
your money yeah but I can see if they if
their first party yeah right but at this
point in time like God
does it make any sense and it's just
Financial sense if you're the head of
square
and there's consoles out there that's
capable of running these games like
Sovereign said they're not too different
from each other
why wouldn't you make the money
I mean look at the end of the day
I still think it's a business model
thing in that business model works for
them they are not
they're trying to protect what they do
and and the the older way of doing
things I just said it's incorrect but
the way it has been for them they want
to keep the status quo this is I've
always said this is a
theoretically this is a business model
battle right this is where Microsoft is
going they don't necessarily want to go
there they're fine where they are and
they recognize you know obviously the
Call of Duty situation is important the
Kingdom Heart games and those games that
came over did well no no oh you talk
about in reference to square I just did
yeah I'm just talking about yeah
with square I mean listen we we can't we
we can not not acknowledge that the
relationship is close like these two
squares responsible Final Fantasy 7 was
huge for for um the PlayStation to get
that respect gotta be careful when using
words
but getting that respect in that space
so it's like
you know that relationship was there
it's been Mutual it's been beneficial so
obviously Xbox comes along they get more
of a footing you know there's some you
know hey we'll put a port here and there
but there hasn't been consistency so I
just think it but who's Square to say
like okay
how are we doing with what we expect to
make and I mean what what we think is
going to make and then what we actually
make and I think what we're seeing right
now is a lot of their
projections have not hit right now it's
up to them to say okay do we change how
we operate with the exclusivity deals
and and as far as uh breaking things up
that remains to be seen and we're going
to learn a lot with this new you know
leadership change at top but yeah
they're definitely going through
something there's no doubt we talked
about the spoken thing we talked about
you know what's been going on they've
been selling off obviously Crystal D and
all this other stuff like it's been they
thought Marvel Avengers was going to be
something they thought Guardians of the
Galaxy was going to be something they've
had some some misses now and as much as
everybody loves their IPs and I think
their IPs are great they have missed and
I don't know if internally maybe they
look at the metrics and say we still
expected Final Fantasy 7 to be bigger or
something like that I don't know maybe
you know what they're you know what
they're doing they're looking at the
numbers and say PlayStation's not enough
are you gonna find out they ain't
laughing and you know and then they're
focusing on smaller projects too like
right a game like octopath sells
gangbusters and how much that game cost
to make right and triangle strategy was
a really good game and trying yeah yeah
we got to see we got to see I'm very
curious I will give you this game I'm
very curious to see how they move in
this new regime now does anything change
in that relationship do they shift from
maybe not doing as many exclusive deals
or is it business is usually status quo
we will see well we'll find out if Final
Fantasy VII actually well seven now
that's the I go for it that's the catch
like I do want to see yeah that's the
contract won't even hold you I've been
dying to know what the verbiage is
I want to see that 16 one as well
because the 16 one is weird as well the
first spoken one and how do contracts
get
I don't say secretly but extend it when
you think it's going to end at a certain
point like is there the option to extend
like how does that work
yeah I'm very exactly do you put that
option in that caveat in from the
beginning from the beginning right also
you know Microsoft did accused of the
can't be on Game Pass like how does that
work like what's the vertebrate like
okay I wonder if like because obviously
I think we have a good feeling that this
this stuff's going to get leaked like
even if it's not public these These are
being like the big stuff for sure yeah
and
and I bet you Sony just sitting there
like damn why did we even go down this
route because I I do think there's a
part of them knew this might happen but
I don't think that they thought
Microsoft would have cause to get this
stuff from them
okay both both are shorted tremendous
tenacity to fight for this that's what
this is and we're seeing the reason that
to King's Point the reasoning being
about how much that that resource I mean
that uh that Financial push from Call of
Duty is to them and then the other part
with Microsoft is one how serious this
they are about Game Pass oh Lord but how
serious they are about that and and two
so these credit they did bikes
like you ain't trying to dive that's
calling duty fam let's keep it a box
so we got to be fair like so fraughtant
on that one it was
fraughty very clear would you be
interested in the best deaf restaurant
oh no no no no the Call of Duty they
could rip Call of Duty apart from that
shout out to to PlayStation and score
Enix for doing that snitching and
getting Microsoft to you know call out
for these documents because I would say
here in the next month we're going to be
very entertained
with the plot thickens April comes off
and and let it be known that at that
Final Fantasy VII contract leaks and
there's and there's some sucker stuff in
that thing let it know that you never
not hear me I will speak from the top of
the highest mountain when you're going
to order acronyms today you're gonna
know who the FTC is
I'll make up a couple more what's
umbrellas
umbrella anyway what's up you got the uh
yeah we got the super chances uh Robert
Kelly Two Dollars they're putting
Minecraft on PS plus month are they
I mean no there's Minecraft dungeons bro
oh okay yeah
um
people acting like that's oh why they do
I mean Sony's literally paying Microsoft
to have that Minecraft on a prank yeah
exactly like people acting like like
that they don't pay for that stuff like
my every time something goes in Game
Pass if something goes in place uh games
for go Microsoft gives them money for
that it's not for free yeah yeah I
remember that
Reggie mobile nine remember for one year
five dollars but that great show as
always how much do you think the APK
deal caused Microsoft To Go Radio silent
on what's going on with games and
development a lot
and it's Sony too it's not just
Microsoft I don't think it's a
coincidence that the only time in
history that I could tell you since I
started covering content which is 2014
that Sony has missed a big uh their big
show every year the only time they've
ever done it is when this Call of Duty
thing happened did you think that
affects announcements in June
I can almost guarantee you the the
moment
I think they'll do one before uh Sony
before Microsoft's still ends up going
through or doesn't go through because I
think there is a point in this lawsuit
and there is a point in this uh this
acquisition where there's nothing either
side can do at that point to to affect
the outcome anymore right and I think
once that point is where Sony knows okay
we did everything we can there's nothing
else that we can do the decisions
already been pretty much made so like
now we can actually start going back to
the way things are we can actually do
our big you know presentation because
it's like I said
the only time they've ever missed that
presentation that big show that E3
caliber presentation was the year that
that acquisition was going through
that's the only time I've ever missed it
and I think I don't think that's a
coincidence they don't they they both
come parties want to seem weak and I
think that's probably why Microsoft may
have did that next 12 month thing to not
show games coming in the future
interesting
interesting we will see yeah yeah that's
for sure then we got akw with the five
pound Super Chat hey addict you forgot
to mention the 4-2a and the 6-4a and the
black M.A and all the ma
is it isn't there a company called 42a
like a gaming developer a rapper called
young Ma
salute to the panel the whole uh ABK
deal is still is in a shakespace
Xbox bios don't celebrate too early keep
the fraud light on Deck oh cover for
king that's my man Phillip Carl I
rapping Sony hard on what's up
Phil
you on the wrong side of History
and you know you can't tell me
not to
I got cigars ready
you can't tell me not the pop bottles
you can't tell me not to
smoke cigars
I'm going to be popping bottles and
smoking cigars
while you're
wiping your eyes
time with this with this I got a tissue
for you you're gonna wipe your eyes
because the deal is going to go through
and I'm gonna be happy and you're gonna
be sad but what I want you to do is come
over here
we got a place for you
okay one thing I want the one thing I
won't go if I've been the knee segment
on with King is this particular moment
because who even if let's say I voted
that it wouldn't go through I lose
regardless so like
you shout out to my man Philip Carlo
Destiny good dude join us I join us
we're gonna be over here anyway it don't
matter
collegiately
here we go Jacob novik with the 50
Swedish krona I love you sir with these
currencies
his passport is stamped
it's all passwords Swedish what's funny
is the chat don't know this but every
time someone you know donates rubies or
pounds soft guy go to that country and
pick it up
I gotta pick it up physically yeah it's
Thomas and sweet and put the money in
the bag
okay we get like that one random
currency that only donated once stop
goes up there for a couple quarters
you got Phil standing in front of his
developer Army be like today we
destroyed PlayStation tomorrow we
conquer the world
is out of pocket right now
your ABK and then next Ubisoft
then we got God Emperor Sofa King two
dollars Sony is currently located on
death row
in his last meal in a second
what do you want to eat beans and rice
chill here we go Jacob Novick once again
with the 20 Swedish krona uh Sony may as
well change their name to Sagan damn bro
y'all better let this deal get blocked
cause y'all popping a lot of bottles
then we got God Emperor super kick again
2006 Sony's Walking The Green Mile
dead man walking again
dead man walking
walking out
this guy right here man this guy
there we go Hollywood rules member for
one year two dollars
oh okay Sony not buying take two and
take and take on 8 000 employees say yes
yes
let's put the crust in the chat forgot
Emperor Sofa King welcome Lord bro
welcome absolutely absolute you
appreciate that then we got Stitch
member for two years five dollar Super
Chat people forgot to uh the comment
that the Take 2 CEO made when talking to
Phil about we have so take two could be
next just saying oh that would be crazy
bam what's good yeah I don't know if
they doing that level again
then we got Dorian Gray two dollar Super
Chat Sony will sign before letting that
info Out imagine like now now okay we're
good we signing that yo you know I
thought that would be true too I thought
they said yo give us the paperwork no
we're sorry
is this sad is this sad that I'm willing
to risk that deal just to see those
papers
if it was up to me I'd be like no it
feels up to me no like at it Sony said
they're going to sign those papers you
don't you just can't see the paperwork
for these deals like nah the deal can be
sacrificed
this scummy and play in person man they
want to see the world burn yeah
let's see and we got splend difference
with his name
I want to see who's gonna be the first
company to say Sony does that we didn't
know they were they were doing that
we're not associated with any kind of
wrongdoing
yo yo By Us by snitching
and the paperwork comes out
Sony is gonna be in turn snitching on
everybody oh you got to deal with Capcom
doing what
no man yo yo Sony what's up
you comply they put the rest of the
industry in danger
it's hilarious
Super Chat King I also smoke cigars what
do you have oh I have uh cherry flavor I
think
um there's so many different flavors in
here
this one smells Divine
time when cigar talk let's move this
[__] go 17 two pounds Super Chat
Jason's trying punch in the air right
now what you gotta be respectful that's
my guy shout out to Jason I'm gonna read
one thing from uh see Beck sent me a DM
on Xbox and he never does this so I just
want to read it we got a sob question
for the Lords on parity if the ABK deal
goes through and Sony signs the deal how
will parody affect the use of Xbox
features like direct storage
Etc will they be used if the other box
doesn't have that feature
well I mean you can't you can't omit the
use of the hard drive on the PlayStation
right you have to right so it it that's
the type of stuff that you kind of let
slide no no
let them operate like a mechanical drive
a little late
I haven't seen that SSD do anything yet
so
you still got a regular hard drive
you know what you know the reason I'm
like let them wait because I gotta wait
for all these final fantasies game they
can wait for a loading screen yo you
know what I really I don't do they
really have a fast ssdna already let's
line up
I haven't seen this instance SSD yet not
even in their own games so I'm just
trying to figure out like was we really
Bamboozled like is it really what they
say or is it just talk because you know
we've been we've been beat with blast
Master processor is this blast Master
processor frame rates have been in so
many favor lately sir
you're gonna put respect on his name I
don't think that has anything to do with
it I believe that's the low resolution
upres
honestly I just haven't seen the the
ssgb what they said it was
well we'll see shout out to Jason
Ronaldo the team and velocity
architecture and all that good stuff but
uh yes sir we shall see
and we got void lock member for 14
months Lord bronze thank you what's up
brother Sony is about to turn into Usher
I'm ready to sign them and Pages
This Is My Confession
bro just when you thought you had me now
you don't
see the papers
[Laughter]
how many podcasts are you gonna make
references like that and we're gonna get
it immediately yeah you have to just
come on man this this is good stuff
premium entertainment
and we got booty remember for 19 months
Lord bronze
enough respect to the Moon down my
original
salute oh he hyped no doubt you're done
no you're done
I love him Boutique I like it he got
that energy he got that energy I love
that
that we got uh Joe Dunmore two dollar
Super Chat it's only had a deal with Don
matrick to kill Xbox
with you I'm upset with the NFL deal
that we um Microsoft had that went away
oh yeah that was a because that was how
I was consuming my NFL to be honest with
you bro yeah once that left I I just
like lost out on the NFL to be honest
are we good that's lucrative that's yeah
lucrative as hell um sir duck remember
for 31 months Lord bronze
yo yo set confessions APK Edition King
is important he got it he got it that
was that was over here
OG had to know what king did him on that
one no no shout out to C Bank no doubt
brother I appreciate it reaching out
appreciate that yeah so we are caught up
all right cool now it's time for me to
check out yeah yeah I'll make it quick
for you so I'll make it quick I'll just
go on my little little bars
no we just lost 36 yeah we're gonna let
this make sure y'all hit the like button
on the way out
you know you know that video I sent you
that the Destiny part was the only part
that wasn't a joke
look we'll make it quick but um look man
it's out obviously it's it's come under
Fire for mixed reviews you know what I'm
saying there's a lot of uh contentious
Parts looking so I mean look at slow mo
you so fatty I'm not good anywhere you
know what I'm saying so look let's talk
about it um I'm just getting my
impressions uh really quickly so I want
to talk about the good first obviously
um it's classic Bungie gameplay it's
tight the Skybox is absolutely gorgeous
the emona looks like a fantastic
um location as far as the the initial
cinematic of getting it started it was
really engaging that the witness is here
the witness is here so basically for
those who don't play Destiny this is
their theoretic Thanos in a way right
this is where we're getting to the end
game type Infinity War type moments for
things they've been talking about for 10
years the darkness the light Saga all of
this stuff as far as from a core
gameplay standpoint the quality of life
stuff is outstanding loadouts commentate
accommodations the mod system much
easier giving it to new players so it's
like oh you didn't have you wasn't there
in week five when we put out this
powerful mod you know saying that you
don't have that you can't do hard
content with like everybody else those
days are over so it's fun to play and I
want to shout out the tormentors you
know one of the thing in destiny that
sometimes the difficulty challenge
can be easy with sub some of the ranking
file guys but what the torment is is it
reminds me of the hive Guardians there's
a level of fear that they bring so yeah
it's a good it's a solid game to grind
post campaign is really fun it's really
good I'm still putting in a ton of hours
so that's that but we gotta we gotta get
to the real here and Bungie I'm gonna
need you to come to the front of the
convocation yes sir tell them because
here's the deal the reason why you're
getting all this smoke is because
this campaign narratively ain't it and
the reason why it ain't it is because
this would solve to give because I know
you don't play this anymore this would
be like us going to the theater for
Avengers end game
they don't tell you why Thanos is doing
what he's doing
they don't tell you what the infinity
gems could do
and then you end the story with no
progression really or what really
happened like the story really didn't
move forward right wow so yeah there was
the lose moment but it wasn't impactful
and you know
wrong
it's equivalent it's equivalent to like
Thanos not telling you what the Infinity
Stones are getting all of them and then
the movie going on right like and the
reason so sinister's saying that it the
raid is going Sinister I love you and
you're hopeful but for all intents and
purposes The Raid is going to be a
separate story that might not
necessarily I hope he's right he's
hopeful you know but the thing the
reason why they got to get the smoke
from me is because
you can't come off the witch Queen which
is a masterpiece in storytelling from
them this is peak bungee this is
literally the story of Sabbath all the
things we thought about to have they
changed the whole that's the universe
upside down in one of the most amazing
plot twists ever the story of the witch
Queen was God tier Bungie legendary
acquisition
that's true watch your mouth but at the
end of the day this is the first one
after the acquisition that's yes watch
your Vibe so this is this this you do it
too much but at the end of the day I'm
not gonna let you you try to dominate
yourself now you try to dominate the
show with your foolishness that's
see a Common Thread
here we go you got a derail the
conversation I'm just I'm just saying
listen I'm I'm in with you I'll purchase
I just didn't finish my campaign right
it's got to Jupiter I don't like us all
right so I like the little Silver Surfer
Dudes I like the Annunaki uh
I'll let you go so look at the end of
the day that's why this is a
disappointment this is B level Story
Time some of these characters the clouds
look cool very Silver Hawks energy shout
out to Silver yeah
I know those were silver hey those is
Ten Feet Tall Silver Hawks we know what
you're doing budget but it's all good
the thing is you can't come off that
great a story and then give us this and
you don't really Advance the plot you
don't explain anything what is a lot of
these things what happened like people
when the lore guy of death Yesterday by
David's wife has to put out a video and
say I don't know what happened wow
so what that shows me again the game is
fire The Strand is a subclass amazing
criminally underrated the mobility you
Insomniac Spiderman and once you learn
it it's fire it's great but the core
game is solid but the native is so
average and some of the character
dialogue is so mid that it just stains
everything that's why everybody's just
bombing it because they're like yo how
you came off Illmatic and then you gave
us Nostradamus you can't do that you
can't give us
yeah
I have requests I did before King goes
all the one thing from the beginning
right that I saw just in the Cinematic
thing was this I wasn't feeling the
antagonist right some people have an
issue with him he like you know chimney
heads
so it just felt weird because it if it's
funny it gave me Quantum Mania energy
where it was like if this guy is that
big of a threat you didn't show it here
and here's the thing what made infinity
War great is the minute it started
Thanos came in no disrespect came out
you know being respectful they showed
you how powerful he is an exertion of
the power that the threat is oh my God
he had a mini moment here and there and
then I don't want to spoil too much it
just
motivation and explanation not doing
that again there's some moments of the
campaign that are phenomenal they're
great moments these times training
Mission a full-scale I don't want to go
so crazy on the core game the core
gameplay and it is fire and this quality
of life I got amazing I can do builds
great but that narrative is interesting
and what it showed me is because this is
Now setting up the final shape which is
the final that's Infinity war end game
for them I am worried because they
botched this so much
how do you now pull us all together so
to me this showed you needed to delay
lightfall the same way you delayed which
Queen and you got like six months and
you got one of the greatest stories my
concern is they're trying to pack in too
much it's too many two threads and you
didn't explain yes there's more seasonal
contact between this but we will see but
I will admit as a destiny fan I am
concerned narratively that they got to
get this I don't know how you get this
backward track and I'm worried about the
narrative for the first time when
they've been so good for about a year to
two years of great narrative this was
unacceptable narrative
it just feels like if you're gonna if if
you really are going to have this world
ending moment like the L has to be
pronounced
this L is no I don't want to spoil for
kid this L is oh that happened bro look
what happened we lost we lost it right
but but what really happened
everything's still the same y'all still
in Infinity War when you lost you knew
you lost
yeah yeah yeah I'm done with my rent um
attic get your balls off and then we
give the kid hey you know um I'm more of
a casual Destiny person these days uh I
don't really care I I ca I care about
the narrative more than anything and
people say well you know the gameplay is
good so like trying to give like brownie
points to to this and I'm like but their
gameplay is always good like I don't I
don't think you can realistically give
them a plus for that because like their
gameplay was always going to be good
we've never had an issue with the game
play you know I I think strand
um I I low-key think this I'm not
worried about the narrative and the
reason I'm not worried is because I was
looking up some videos and they
originally it seems like this wasn't
like I didn't realize that video they
showed all of them come out
I didn't realize that that that uh the
the the the other one wasn't on that
list right uh what it what's the next
one the uh shapes the final shape the
final shape is the final shape expansion
I didn't realize that wasn't on that
year when they said all those games yes
correct uh they announced that during
the witch Queen yes uh so I I I I I
actually I believe the the rumors I
think that you know they needed more
time on on the the shape whatever it is
final shape and um they switched the
majority of lightfall to final shape and
they they did the because it was rumored
that strain was supposed to come out
during the witch Queen yeah that's right
with delay because you could tell and
yeah
it actually makes sense and I think at
this point
imagine how lit which Queen would have
been with strand there oh yes so uh
Masterpiece slave I do agree with with a
lot of people are saying they think that
um
that maybe they should have just delayed
a year and not had something come out
this year it just had strain come out
and look during the witch Queen because
I do feel like as much as I think that
they'll be fine because there was a
reason this happened and I think that it
was bunchy's fault
they should add better contingency plans
but I as long as their original Vision
was good I think they'll be fine when
the actual expansion comes out or
they'll they'll they'll they'll drop the
ball on that too only time will tell uh
but you know I I think they'll be fine
you know but I am disappointed with this
I I think you know I was talking to
smooth and I was like you know what's
funny because he asked me uh what I
thought about the expansion because he
saw all this negative so all this
this beef and I was like let me put it
to you this way narrative wise I know
just as much about Destiny that I do a
month ago yeah didn't learn yep I agree
quickly
any expansion any any game
that that's not a good look exactly it's
not you know you always want to ex you
always want to push the ball down the
road right but it's it's like they they
lost the ball and now they're looking
for it like and it's frustrating because
I'm scared for the raid
because it what is the rage shoe horned
in here like because to me it seems like
they they came up with all this like the
Strand story and stuff on the whim
because if you think about a lot of the
story is the strength so if they if they
did come up on the whim
what what's what's what's the rate is
that a whim too like I'm just concerned
on the quality of the rate and if the
quality of the rates bad then you're
gonna get a completely different beat
yeah we'll see we'll see I mean a lot I
don't I'm not I hear what you're saying
the the problem I think is that we've
had this discussion with Travis is that
when you have the seasonal content and
shout out to Travis he called he called
it so the shot Trav you called it but I
was wrong I could call it brother
um the thing that we had are Tom
formsworth from Bungie on last word
right about it to the homie so one thing
he said about the seasonal content is
that is self-contained in the sense that
it doesn't move the think of Deceit like
think of it as kind of like the the
Marvel the Disney plus is the season
right the expansions for Destiny are
kind of like the MCU big budget choice
so you're not gonna in this period
between experience you're not going to
get you need stuff that moves along but
not major things all the time so I guess
that's the concern so I think that the
frustration some people have is some of
that content is kind of spin-off content
where things kind of it feels like a
season right that's what this felt like
yeah and the sad part is the reason I'm
concerned if they never intended on the
story and they had a shoehorn this story
at the last minute that's why I could
start with the rate it's like well did
do you have cohesive thoughts on the
raid is it well thought of or is it just
more of this just a last minute thing
you had to do well it's obviously not
last minute it took the months to do
this for sure for sure but it's
at the end of the day if this expansion
wasn't planned to go the way this
expansion went and they pushed a lot of
that content to you know uh the other
one I'm gonna call it the other yeah
photo shape photo shape so if they push
it to the final shape it makes me
worried about anything else not the not
the the seasons because I think the
seasons are going to be exactly how they
were saying the new seasonal content is
good if if you split concert to make
another whole expansion and it seemed
like they took more out of this
expansion to give to the final shape
what is the ray gonna look like on here
maybe it was never even intended to be
done
all of it was shoehorned at the same
time we'll see I think the last one I
said before I give it to solvocate is
that
um because you could tell they're seeing
the negative response all right oh yeah
especially how they opened up
so what that tells me and then they're
very key to say
the story of the witness and all this
other stuff is going to so to me that
denotes I'm just I'm just guessing that
they intend to tell that story that
probably should have been wrapped up all
the way in lightfall through the
seasonal content up until that the key
is going to be the execution a lot of
people some people like are like King
now they they feel Destiny is homework
for the season and they want to go to
the expansion to see the how the game
has moved forward and all the content
and the quality of life stuff that's
what witch Queen gave so we have to see
it's going to be on them you know the
real MVP is yeah
shout out to that marketing team oh for
Bungie that made me buy into this stuff
great
because they they could they could sell
you a rock and and make you think it's
everything's fine now shout out to
spread it he said it sounds worse than
commercial size no I'm not going to go
there I will say for Destiny 2
expansions which Queen is God till we're
gonna say forsaken is definitely number
two I have it probably number three or
four I know so I mean I know you
probably have Shadow kid I have it over
Shadow keep and Beyond like I think it's
still a solid it's just that you just
came from Mount Rushmore and you've
given us mid so that that's over where
you have it I have it I'd be on light
over this okay it's still up in the air
for shadow keep uh because I just I
think the it's like I said the biggest
reason that I I'm really hard on this
one is because they killed a character
that I beloved was callous and that's
the
reasons come on man no I'm talking about
the character oh yeah let's talk about
spoilers
some people didn't know that happened
but we gotta move on so um no no I'm not
talking about like death I'm talking
about they killed him as oh as a
character okay okay like the character
from the Leviathan I feel like it's the
same person like I see what you're going
I see what you call it you cleaned that
up that was very close anyway a soft
King you know anyone will jump in let's
all got his bars off he's finished
I would
that can go and I'll finish out there
because I have some questions about what
y'all feel moving forward yeah no doubt
King all right oh Tom
um you know uh just figured it out uh
the flavors is on the back or your
PlayStation okay Amaretto Peach vanilla
and orange okay so I wasn't being rude I
just couldn't read it anyway so I'm
ready to run the back side you're good
um
okay so lightful we purchased this a
while ago and I was like and I actually
have got it by mistake because I was
supposed to get the season pass or
something like that Sovereign remembers
that whole thing yeah I was like how
much is that my coach the iron back was
not happy with that color
we got that thing day of like you know
and he's an easy he doesn't care about
it you know Cog definitely cares and
attic I don't know where he falls into
it all the way I think he wants the
story more or less
um because that's all I heard from you
guys with stories yes when I loaded it
up and you know I got in I was looking
at all the stuff I love the witness I
love his eyes I love the head I love the
fact that he's he he looks mischievous
he has a little mouth coverage so he has
his covet mask oh you know what he looks
like he looks like a good mask what's
those things in x-com like the basic
things yeah yeah he looks like an adult
version of that sticky eyes
do y'all think he is the real big bad
that is the there is there is a person
I've got his name I want to give him
props who put out a video that literally
explained the story of life for better
than budgie and now I have an
understanding I think of what's going on
so that what you said I will send you
that video okay it's a great video this
this
do Force I don't care what nobody said
because uh the witness uh I mean not the
witnessed The Traveler did something and
towards the witness and the witness
sector weights thank you spring yeah
that sector is from x-comp sorry he he
just went you know he went through and
he was in in the air floating in doing
some stuff and you know oh boy is
definitely probably the most powerful
villain I've seen so far from Destiny
yes this is from where I'm at so I get
to the planet
the Anunnaki is there
so you have
um a younger Annunaki dude and you have
an older one who reminds me of like a
mature version of Thor because he has
this weird Hammer with a sickle at the
end and they're on the surfboards like
Silver Surfer yeah so they co-opt a lot
of stuff they Co-op silverhawks silver
hooks they co-opt the Annunaki yes they
Co-op uh Silver Surfer yes
but these guys do not possess the
ability to resurrect itself because they
don't they're not light bearers correct
right so when you show up you're a light
bearer now I got a call Bungie out on
the carpet on this uh the engine is old
now
um it's very sparse the world of Jupiter
when you get there maybe it sparse
because you're using the Spider-Man
technique and they want you to be able
to have enough room and not bump into
stuff I get it right but also at the
same time the veil we have to show that
we're not uh two generations ago this
this feels very 360-ish PlayStation
Destiny still on those older consoles
the PS4 right and they need to just get
them
um but I know you're not gonna dead that
bread now this is the this is the first
expansion after the acquisition
and I don't know if Bungie looks over
because you know Bungie looks for
reasons to leave right maybe they look
over and be like oh man we just ain't
really good it ain't really working out
I don't think these dudes is really
working
um
you decided to figure out how to get up
out of that contract oh here we go I see
what he does but not even that right so
right back to this thing yo why your man
why your man who the young dude gotta
have the dishes
gotta be face first like I'm like come
on man
William screams at the same thing he
wasn't he wasn't feeling that I'm like
yo the other dude is respectful this
jungle covered everything wow the young
dude is
man come on man
it's kind of crazy it's very crazy in
the beginning you're like what is going
on here with these dudes
um and then you don't know if they
Friend or Foe because they was like
we're glad that you're here and we're
fighting beside you and not fighting you
um right so you had options to fight me
like what's up and get marked if we had
a fight then it wouldn't even be a fight
because they ain't got no revive
so but so far what I'm playing I felt at
home I went to uh the menus and I've
noticed a couple of things like
um
they made things easier right because
before how you put your mods in your
stuff like that now you have a whole
screen of it and your character is there
and you can place your mods inside that
looks dope
um the the season pass is always fun uh
the bowl
that you get in the beginning of the
season pass is a good workable exotic
the game is it felt like home so I
didn't feel too far removed the story
has me super intrigued like I'm very
early on I just got to Jupiter guys okay
and I just finished one portion I mean
Neptune um I just finished one portion
of um the the story campaign and I'm
going to start it off again and do it
because I went down there I saw
everybody running around because the
world is very active right so I saw real
people running around and doing
um like uh what is that uh uh activity
control kind of thing yeah Patrol
activities and I'm seeing it I'm like
let me join in there then for the first
time since Destiny won
I saw skull and crossbones oh yeah
over there yeah so the normal little
guys in one shot kill you so I'm I'm
sitting there trying to get in the mix
with the big homies big homies is
fighting I'm trying to hang out with
them in there let me let me see if I can
eat off the plate nah I got smoke
he's like go do your campaign
get your light level up yeah but um it's
it's it's very colorful I love the 80s
feel it has a real 80s feel very
disco yes I think there's a lot of
attention to detailing out there though
like a lot of like the characters feel
really Bland yeah
that's that's and I think that's the
engine I think the engine needs to
update I don't know what Sony's willing
to finance that so I mean that might be
pushed back off that you know they might
be like yo we need some more bucks to
get this you know and they're gonna be
like but we just paid the three billion
nah but we do need to update you know
the house because you know the
foundation is a little bit you know we
we need you know we want to do it
outside and Sony might not have the cash
for that so this might be the reason for
us people the next expansion will be you
know them on their own you know how
bungee do so I'm just saying it's fun so
far I did have somebody ask me
um King uh should I get Destiny I see
you playing it and you know because we
play fortnite together and I and I told
him I said hell no
if you've never played it if you never
got into it this is a college
intimidating it's it's very grindy uh
you won't level up as fast as you wanna
it's it's very very grindy attic is what
you 1760 or something like that you said
17 almost 17 80. you see and no I'm not
even nowhere close to that and you have
to do these things daily so I noticed
that and I was like well I'm right back
in it you know we spend this money on it
I'm gonna have to you know play it but I
do say this I'm playing because I love
the character of the witness I love his
Aesthetics I love I love the fact that
he doesn't talk too much here
I I love him
um I loved it from before when they
showed him and the little hands in the
head and all that other stuff to smoke I
love the character I hope to expound on
it I love where they're going with it I
don't feel cheated and I don't feel
disappointed but I haven't finished the
campaign to say that so let me finish
that next week I get back and report
back to you guys but so far if your
destiny head I'm having fun with it I
would say try it out don't buy the
season pass but try it out uh or or if
your destiny had you already in so I'll
get you on the Playfield no doubt solve
for any questions before you get up out
of here yeah I just want to ask you guys
like what what do you think is the cause
of all these these Hills and Valleys
with the quality like because you know
like when they broke off from Activision
you could say okay they are back on
their own now they gotta handle all this
themselves and in a way they didn't have
the pressure of it has to come out
within this time from whatever they they
pick their own time frames right and we
saw the quality go up but you could see
like the bag wasn't as big right they
needed to get their footing again and
then when we thought they were going to
stay independent I was sudden you know
they take it back from Sony and they're
once again within that within that sort
of regime but the according to what you
know what we know what we think we know
it they have kind of complete autonomy
within that why is it did you do you
guys have any thoughts on why the Hills
and Valleys when it comes to it can't be
like
I don't feel like they have in in turn
pressure from someone need to release a
certain time frames it ain't ready it
ain't ready
um because that again that King was
saying that would be that would be a a
prime reason to for the divorce there
are theories yeah right so what do y'all
think yeah well I think there's a lot of
theories here one is
you know what we got to talk about the
elephant in the room yes they've been
acquired we know that we know that
they've been acquired primarily not only
for the destiny franchise but primarily
for their live service Acumen to help
Sony fun projects in that space which
they are deficient we say what you want
about Destiny you don't like it but you
can't say the gun play you can't say as
far as that first person shooting and
live service model they have survived
all of these quote-unquote Destiny
killers they are the ogs and they make
that Revenue despite 50 zillion uh
business models that you guys have but
we go we're gonna move on we're gonna
move on but um I think there could be
that could be part of it the other thing
is we've known that they are developing
another title which is called matter
which is um I forgot the genres almost
like a I think it's like a hero shooter
kind of thing in a b2p space and the the
main complaint recently has been that
the PVP portion of Destiny is grossly
neglected this is what with me Travis
Eddie bontes always talk about the
destiny is three components It's usually
the campaign the PVE stuff Gambit I
don't know if you said that mode and
then Crucible Crucible when Destiny had
content droughts things like Trials of
Osiris things of new maps everything we
don't even get we rarely get maps now
like we rarely get that kind of stuff so
Crucible has taken a substantial
backseat and now everything is PVE
everything is seasonal model right yeah
so you got that part and then you know
we got to be real I mean there is a
potential I gotta be real
they have been since the remote I don't
know if it's a combination of the remote
working all remote they have been a
little more buggy than lately
more yo these not Exotics ain't gonna
work this ain't gonna work we're
disabling this oh you can't like get it
live service is going to have problems
but they have been more buggier lately
than normal
yeah it's another timeline you know
they've been more buggy since Sony again
theories the theories about look Travis
is which okay he he feels you know that
Sony may be a brain drain on them
and that they may have
they may have lost the secret sauce
which makes them unique because now they
have all these responsibilities we will
see I don't know they're working on
stuff so they're being spreading out on
this 10 games that we got I don't know
all I can comment is this I can look at
the evidence the evidence is the game
has been substantially more buggy lately
the evidence has been The Crucible has
not shown any substantial
updates and love the way is it safe to
say that Sony acquiring stuff they may
be meddling in and maybe uh too much too
Hands-On they they might be hurting
generally the way game development work
is this stuff was already made prior to
acquisition they're usually a full
season so the final shape and all that
stuff while there may be touch-ups was
already in development before Sony was a
client okay
so the question another question yeah
just just Playing devil's advocacy yes
yes please maybe they were on track to
do it before but since with all this new
responsibility you know um you know it's
valid Games Live service Games Live
service games and they need to help out
you know get those up and running help
them you know
um maybe you know uh that that's the
drain on them because they can't focus
on their stuff that's why buggy or stuff
happens you know after the acquisition I
mean is that possible it is possible if
responsibilities are there and then
they've to Sony I don't know you know
what I'm saying and if they
the let their food paperwork
what would be funny though
when did when did taking kick it don't
last before what's what would be funny
is during the days of when they had the
accidentally had the marketing rights I
mean that would be funny if that stuff
came out but anyway look we will see I
don't know for sure but I just have to
be honest I love this game you know we
just came off one of the greatest
expansions so they've shown me what Peak
bungee could do just recently so we just
got to figure it out and they're getting
they're getting the smoke the community
has the top guys are like nah yeah
that's Mid-K like y'all got to get it
together on this narrative part game
itself great numbers still banging out
steam doing concurrent use they're still
in a good position but yeah I mean we
just gotta see we just gotta see cool
cool cool all right that's all I got we
are good espinito yeah
okay let me see hold on a second hey Cox
not defending budgie Sony you don't hear
making excuses that was funny that was
funny a better question what's King
streaming uh should I read the poll
while you get it together
uh so oh necromancing today I got it
got necromancers there I remember for
one year tennis Jack Callus deserved
better he was too good of a character
for that to happen oh Mom I'm out of
here
strands shouldn't have been in the
campaign story Rohan needed more Story
Time valid points on all three I'm 100
agree then we got Necromancer Zale
member for one year 2006 Nimbus is a meh
character with horrible lines 100 agree
I'm not gonna fight you there
then we have Corey Tidwell five dollars
which that nasty nasty s go to Escobar
nah he is Nostradamus man that was
garbage that's my man
some of us
have angels
continue
Italian Brown remember four months two
dollars the Super Chat PlayStation 4 fun
to see that and that's what happened oh
yeah they go all the theories and we got
three R Kelly five dollars with that to
put it bluntly this expansion needed to
not needed to knock and it didn't which
Queen felt way grander in the overall
story this felt like 20 DLC
I think the biggest problem is I was
expecting
way above something like witch Queen
because of the conditions this after
this DLC was standing up because like
Cox said it was supposed to be like the
infinity War kind of moment like it's
setting up for like one of the most epic
moments and it did set up stuff I just
felt like it didn't do it very well
agreed 100
okay and then we have we see Robert
kellett two dollars in the chat so skip
light four if you're a Destiny 2 newbie
like me oh question question no you need
to play witch Queen sir you need to play
with if you're new please play them at
their best please go get the Witch and
see why then you understand why we upset
because it was masterful there's no
looter shooter that is Halo 3 energy
bungee that is Bungie at its Peak form
that we've known him since the Halo days
that's our greatest and sorry I see you
in there being slanderous not even uh
Warframe could do a story
then we got Phillip Carlisle ten dollars
for chat I'm very disappointed in
lightfall the building up to light fall
wasn't strong as which queen as which
Queens build up this was supposed to be
Avengers Infinity War the stakes didn't
feel high enough for me shaking my head
disagree with the build actually the
build up for lightfoil was better than
witch Queen the Builder for life that's
another reason why this hurt so much
they actually had an amazing season
prize season of the serif into this was
amazing and a beautiful cutscene that's
explained so yeah they they just the
actual content was not it so I actually
think that is better than which Full the
leader
and we got slow more back slap metal for
two years ten dollars
heard the names of the next three
Destiny Seasons leaked the season of the
nothing season of the before and season
of the youth put it all together it's
nothing for you
you know what I can't even fight you in
it enjoy it enjoy your game those are
bars
you got season of the mobile
you are an app sir a division to a
season of the decommissioned
you're out of here leave us alone get
your Play account
I love that I love that and guess who's
not in this
that was a good clap that was a good
clap no doubt even snowball laughs
then we have Texas five dollar Super
Chat and I I this is a this is a good
point Lord's lightfo may have been
planned to be lesser of a hit than witch
Queen because final shape has to knock
everyone off their feet sure so so what
if they kind of lure you to sleep and
give you a false sense of security and
like boredom because like nah this is
and then they they murder you with final
shape and it's like again if this is
supposed to be some world-ending thing
I can see that too but it is no excuse
to making you pay for the mediocrity
because yeah the problem is you can do
the mid-season finale just tell the damn
story and explain what happened well
that's what they didn't do they didn't
explain what happened and it Stakes it
just fell flat but yeah
the Grim roles yeah what's I got to send
you a video to some dude that explains
their story better than them you know it
is what it is but a lot last Point um
yeah I think I think it's typical Bungie
that they will you know Father's Day
will be fired whatever that's how they
they kind of like sometimes like that
Bungie's been notorious I mean I hope
this ain't a Sony effect oh God
I mean listen man if finals form or
final shape you know after he got the
veil and final form if it doesn't reach
final form like it doesn't it don't hit
yeah it's gonna be small that's gonna be
the breakup you're gonna see you're
gonna see the breakup is gonna happen
it's gonna be the Kanye Kim Kardashian
breakup and we're gonna know all about
it so yeah you're gonna be out to your
point when the beef with Activision
split started they were not happy with
forsake which was fantastic they would
have happened they wanted bigger numbers
from Bungie was like oh no no no we're
proud of forsaken that's the first time
they ripped you're in the disrespect
yeah and that's when eventually what
happened
he's learned that lesson and doesn't
come out and well assume Sony Sony's
been letting Bungie do whatever they
want to do
it and you know we're gonna do whatever
we want to do and yeah we're going to be
wherever we want to be you ain't gonna
lock us no place and you know Sony was
like cool all right
definitely tough continue
uh that we get anymore nothing we're
good
with Sony potentially forced to reveal
PlayStation exclusivity deals to the FTC
and Xbox
which of these potential scenarios do
you think Sony values the most a
extended length of PlayStation
exclusivity contracts B marketing rights
on the biggest third-party games C
blocking third-party titles from Game
Pass or D I don't care so they still
gonna block this deal
those are the choices Rock the vote when
it goes up on Twitter
shout out to the team shout out to
everybody that came through Lord attic
very patient dying under the stream
we're gonna find people find you sir
follow me on Twitter at Lord IOP you can
find me on r r this Tuesday at 5 00 p.m
I'm sorry about uh Missing Wednesday
like uh I had a show last week I just
completely spaced I was at the gym I was
on my way home and I was like oh God
the attic show an hour ago
so you know appreciate everyone coming
through like I said I'm going to be
doing uh you know more reactions uh I
haven't I haven't watched the new Attack
on Titan episode so I think I'm going to
record me watching that and put that on
there probably Monday so I'm sure you'll
enjoy that dip down I'm sure you in the
chat
um you know King is going to react to
more um Attack on Titan here soon and I
actually have an idea I'm gonna start
doing here probably next month but every
year we're coming through we had up to
like I think 800 people at once
great show you know I like when it's
just us man you know somehow we still go
almost five hours yeah
hey but one thing I will say is not only
did I get the Catalyst for my
Quicksilver I I did it he got mad he was
productive
salute salute the Lord solve we're gonna
find people find you with you oh and
that those reactions are on our patreon
and I'll put it in the chat and you guys
can go watch it if you guys want to no
doubt what's up
working working gotta go do gotta go do
the thing um I'm mad though yeah it's I
was supposed to be able to play
something and maybe talk about it and
did not get to do that uh so yeah
yeah but whatever but
that's it Lord King very spicy today
awesome a lot of grown men in their
feelings with you once again yeah I love
it
I take the Strays I take the bullets for
you that's fine I love when grown men
cry pause they get a five people find
you um antagonizing people
Monday I have to go see operation
Fortune
um that that guy Richie film uh so and
today I gotta watch The Last of Us I
gotta watch uh the episodes of bad [__]
I gotta get the Mandalorian so I got a
whole bunch of stuff to do uh because we
have Arnold with the Lord's Tuesday at 5
p.m uh this week you catch uh Lords of
gamings.net finest myself and Thai
talking about uh the bad batch and
Mandalorian so catch the Lord's minute
at you know Lords of gaming.net go ahead
check that stuff out
uh trying to get some Destiny done uh
trying to also finish up fortnite
because on the eighth uh some of the
stuff from fortnite is going to go away
because the season is up actually yep so
I have to get that stuff done uh so this
season of lightfold just started and you
know it's just fun to have games you
know you have a fighting game that's
launching on the sixth Guilty Gear on on
Game Pass which is dope um it's we had a
great time are we in a Renaissance in
gaming and and I think it's a fun space
to be in I also have to get myself on my
PlayStation to finish up a lot of those
games that's over there and we have
Nintendo getting ready to kick the door
down held it in a minute we have packs
East that we're going to everybody that
showed up today and and um super chatted
uh purchase uh subscription for people
that brought pillows that you know that
did everything and even if you did none
of those
you showed up and you spend time with us
and I appreciate you we had almost uh
800 wow and 30 people here on a Sunday
yeah talk video games with us and this
means so much to us trust me
um so even you showing up even if you
don't purchase anything you hear I
appreciate everything that you do share
it out let's get those likes up and
let's get at it playing one of these
retro games
we got Lord Metroid two dollars to
protect King enjoy the stogies uh tears
of the Kingdom Game of the Year all good
yeah yo no the stogies is gonna be live
on the air when the APK dealer goes down
okay that's what we're doing salute
salute man again salute to the
communities with everybody pulling up
again I just want to give a super
special shout out to Lords of gaming.net
man the whole team is absolutely on fire
we're having some of our best content
some of my best month I I highly
appreciate you guys retweeting the
article clicking the links we're
independent site we're doing big things
we got more things cooking shout out the
attic for really fueling a lot of this
fantastic World Long coverage we are
destroying the game right now to see you
know things kind of popping for the for
the Indies you know what I'm saying on
us because we we got some of the best
talent best teams editorial the whole
bit so salute to y'all I really
appreciate y'all that's all I got and
I'm telling y'all right now stay tuned
to IOP we got things cooking for y'all
coming that's right but that's all I got
anything else y'all are we out y'all got
rice and beers from Sony peace
King King won the the
we already at the outro
too late we don't believe you
[Music]
thank you